This is Jocko podcast number 52 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo.
Good evening.
So
today is the 52nd episode of the Jocko podcast,
which means that it's been one year since we put out one every week and people
been asking me,
you know,
hey,
you got to do anything special for the one year anniversary.
A special guest or a special book is,
you know,
what are you going to do special on this day?
And my answer is yes,
we are going to do something special because today is special.
But today isn't special because it's the 52nd podcast.
Does he just just like I don't go overboard with special holidays like birthdays
or Christmas or Valentine's Day or veterans day or even Memorial Day
today isn't special because it's the 52nd podcast today is special
because it's today.
Today is special because we are alive because we're breathing.
And when you're here and you're alive and you recognize that,
recognize that that's you're alive today,
that makes every day special,
makes every day a miracle,
makes everyday a gift.
And that might seem like a
tripe platitude,
but it isn't.
And if you've seen brave young men who give their lives on the battlefield for
their brothers,
or you've seen stoic young children facing some kind of terminal disease,
or you would have had deaf,
okay,
attack your life with its multitude of heartless weapons,
cancer and disease and suicide and accidents and addiction and murder and war.
And if you've seen those things,
then you know it isn't a platitude and it isn't cliche.
You know,
it's true
every day.
It's a special day.
Every day is a gift.
Every day is awesome.
Okay,
and so what are we going to do special for this podcast right here?
The same thing that we always do.
We're going to give it everything we've got.
We're going to leave it all on the mat.
We prepared,
we invested,
we studied,
we thought,
and we're going to get after it.
Why
not?
Because this is number 52 not because it's been one year,
not because we made it this far,
but because this is the one,
it's the one,
the one life we have,
this is the one shot we get at today,
this day now.
And so we're going to get after it like we always do and we're going to make it
count.
So
yeah.
Cool.
Let's do this now.
I did go a little bit long with the last last podcast.
You know,
we were introducing the Korean War and the coldest war on that last episode.
So I went a little,
I went a little crazy on that one.
Amen.
We all need to hear about that and we're going to hear some more.
But today we're going straight to Q and a
from,
from the interwebs.
So Echo Charles,
what do you got?
Question number one.
Go.
All right.
Okay.
First Question Jocko.
How did you have time to train in martial arts while deployed?
I figure that you were too busy with combat team and think about training while
deployed.
Thank you for any information.
Okay.
So,
um,
a couple things.
I always brought mats with me when we deployed and there was really good,
you know,
cause then once I was in a leadership position,
I could kind of make that happen pretty easily.
How does that,
how does that happen?
Do you just say,
Hey,
do you tell somebody mats?
No,
I had mats and actually got matched from the team and then we would just put
them on a big palette.
When you deploy you,
you go on,
you put all your gear on these big pallets.
So some of those pallets would have mats on mats.
And then when we would go into plumbing,
I prewar it was,
you know,
we,
we go on deployment,
we'd just bring mats and train wherever we could train.
And then once the war started in,
I still brought mats.
Those are,
hey war,
there isn't,
it's not like we're going to have us working 24 hours a day.
So,
and if they did,
we just wouldn't be able to train.
But I was prepared for training.
And what would I did both of my deployments to Iraq is I had a,
what's called a GP medium tent,
which is basically a really,
really big tent and they have air conditioning and they have dual walls so it
stays kind of cool and I just made that into a little mini fight room,
put mats out and then I would just train right when there was downtime and there
is downtime when you're on deployment,
I mean there is definitely downtime or you're on deployment and like what are
you going to do with your downtime is the question.
Now some guys with their downtime,
they decide to do something that's maybe not super productive.
Give you an example that there was some guys on my first deployment to Iraq and
they played halo.
It's a video game.
Have you heard of it?
Okay.
It's a first person shooter video game and so my guys were,
so they just played anytime we weren't working,
which you know our missions at that point,
we're doing a little direct action missions.
They don't take a few hours even,
you know,
the planning and you know,
every two or three days.
So you had time,
right?
And so all the time,
and they had the,
they had wires set up so they could play different,
um,
each other in different tents.
It was really ridiculous.
And meanwhile,
the guys that were a little more hardcore,
we were training,
she has butter but,
but these guys,
and actually these guys were good mugs too.
But what's funny is,
so I kind of thought like,
what is wrong with these guys?
Why are they doing this?
But you know,
whatever.
And then all of a sudden they had a,
the,
the group above us,
the group that was in charge of the seals that were there,
um,
it's called the CG soda.
If the Combined Joint Special Operations Task Force,
that group,
they hosted a halo tournaments,
like in all the different special operations groups went and did this halo
tournament.
And I don't know if I'm proud of this or not proud of this,
but two of my guys that entered the tournament,
they,
they compete,
they won.
But not only did they want,
when,
I guess the way you play Halo you get,
you can die multiple times.
And so after a certain number of times,
like you play to a certain number of deaths I guess.
But anyways,
the,
in the finals,
these two guys beat the other guys that were from some army group or,
or something.
They beat them 50 deaths to too.
So I was just saying to myself,
really,
uh,
so many ways,
the next deployment guys were playing some other,
I never,
I,
I don't play video games,
but the other guys played in when we were in Ramadi,
guys were playing,
I want to say John Madden football.
That's a good one.
Yeah.
See,
I don't know cause I don't play video games,
the Echo Charles.
But uh,
but what I was doing during those times,
during those downtimes is yes,
bring,
um,
bring maths and train Jujitsu.
And there's always guys,
even though there'd be plenty of guys playing video games and we'd,
we'd trained Jujitsu for sure.
And you should make time for it because you know what you think about,
um,
being under a stressful situation.
Well,
what's gonna help you with a stressful situation,
a physical outlet,
a little mental break.
And guess what?
Guess what gives you a physical outlet and gives you a mental break and doing
some Jujitsu.
So,
you know,
of course there's times where we'd go and we'd go in the field or we'd have
multiple back to back to back to back operations and we won't build a train.
No big deal.
Of course their job takes the total priority over it.
But um,
yeah,
so I would always train and,
and I'll tell you one more thing.
When I would go on deployment,
like let's say you're a guy that trains and you go on deployment,
well there's going to be somebody that will train with you even if there are
never trained before somebody is going to go,
yeah,
I'll train with you.
And those guys,
that's it.
That happened to me where I went on deployment with a bunch of guys that didn't
know anything and I just was teaching them.
And when I came back from a six month deployment,
this is before the war.
I was definitely way better than I was before I left.
So even though I was only training with guys that were not even close to as good
as me,
just training all the time and just going with guys,
you know,
strong,
tough team guys made me better and when I got back I had improved a lot in
comparison with the guys that I was training with before I left that will trade
it all the time while I was gone.
So you can make improvement even if you're just have bodies to move around and
you can focus on your offense,
you can put yourself in bad positions.
This isn't a bunch of ways to get better while you're doing it.
So yeah man,
you can train,
you can train on deployment for sure.
We just had a couple of guys come back from deployment from the Marine Corps and
you know,
they were on a shipboard deployment.
They trained all the time,
you know,
then just came back to victory in the and the,
they've been training the whole time.
They got good too.
They improve their game a lot.
Yeah,
I seen guys train,
I think it was army guys.
They're training,
they train with the jacket on and they use the jacket.
I mean different but kind of this,
oh yeah,
it's the same,
you know,
and I've done that too.
Uh,
in fact the early days of Jujitsu for me,
I spent,
that's why when know started getting popular,
I kinda knew Nogi because we used to train in BDU pants,
so like camouflage pants and a tee shirt that was sort of,
that's sort of seemed like a good compromise.
And then,
and plus dean and I trained no Gila even though Dean was,
Dean was trained in Nogi cause he wrestled in and isn't he doing MMA stuff too
then what he did,
he did know way before he did,
uh,
before he did MMA.
I mean we are trading,
no,
Gee,
I don't even know what our last dean,
where the idea came because even in Samo you wear a jacket.
Right.
And he was a Samba guy too.
Do you guys go like all when you train,
like,
Hey,
I'm a,
you know,
I'm just one of the team guys.
I don't train Jiu Jitsu and you're like,
hey,
let's go train.
What did you do full on training?
Like six,
eight minute rounds or it's the same thing.
I mean I've talked about before,
like I would get guys that were training,
even if they're a lower level and I'm just trained with all of them and just
line them up and go and then they'd be trading with each other too,
you know?
And I would teach little classes and say,
hey,
this is how you do this and you know,
you,
you know me,
I kind of liked a role more but so I would always end up rolling a lot.
But you know,
you get good tough team guys that wrestled or their high school or they did
judo.
So there's guys and they always bring it,
it's always good training and they're moving and they got great cardio and a
strong,
and then,
you know,
anytime there was marines around or,
or soldiers around,
there's some rangers down the street from me.
I trained with a few of those guys a couple of times,
so yeah,
man,
getting after it.
You can definitely,
you got to find a way to do it and then you make time to do it.
Next question.
My boss instituted mandatory uncompensated monthly meetings with the added
warning that if we miss them there'd be repercussions.
Well,
this is an unjust move on his part.
I'm choosing to remain silent and not complain.
I decided that this is not enough of a,
of a pressing issue for me to speak out against that when the next time I
decided to actually raise an issue over something,
it'll have more of an impact.
This was influenced by your decision to only ask for or ask your leadership for
help only when absolutely necessary because of this.
When you did ask for something,
you request was taken much more seriously.
Do you think this was the right way to lead up the chain of command in this
scenario?
Yeah.
I think that's all very good way to lead up the chain of command in that
scenario,
and you got to choose your battles because it is possible in any job to to cry
wolf,
right?
It's possible to say,
oh,
well this is this way.
We can't do this.
And it's,
it's possible if you complain about everything,
eventually you're not getting listened to any more.
So what I would do here,
definitely attend the meetings,
right?
You show up for the meetings,
you tend the meetings,
you see what they're about to see,
what the deal is,
what is he trying to accomplish?
Maybe he has some really good thing that he's trying to accomplish.
Got To put out word or we don't know yet.
Maybe his vision is that this only going to only gonna hold these mandatory
meetings until he gets a flow and it gets everybody on board and then he can go,
cool,
we don't have to do this anymore.
You guys got it.
I don't know what his vision is.
Your,
no,
what's he trying to make happen?
Let's give him that credit as the leader to say,
hey,
you know,
you're calling this meeting,
we're going to show up there,
we're going to do our best to participate and,
and get the most out of the meeting.
Find out what it's all about.
So go to the meetings and then now you got your guys.
So you're might be a little bit worried about your guys' right.
Saying,
hey,
why are you making us a dentist meeting that the said we got to go to and on
that one,
what I would likely do is make everyone attended a few of them and I would do
it.
So hey guys,
the boss is having a meeting.
No,
we're not going to get paid,
but look,
we're going to get word where to find out what's going on.
So I want everyone's,
everyone's got to be there,
right?
So you don't pass the buck,
you,
you maintain the,
the responsibility of what's happening.
You own it.
And then maybe,
maybe after a little while though,
you look at the Boston,
he said,
hey boss,
you know what?
These meetings are good to go.
I'm getting a lot out of them but I'm not going to make my,
I don't want to make my guys go,
I want to pass the word to them.
So is that all right if I have them skip the meetings but I'll be there and then
I'll put out the information and you know,
most likely you'll get a,
hey that sounds good.
Es specially if you've been attending the meetings and you've been
participating,
you've been raising your hand and saying taking notes and saying yeah we got
that boss.
We can make that happen if you've been,
is that kissing ass?
No,
no,
no.
It's building relationship right now.
There is a distinction right between kissing ass and building relationship and
don't kiss ass because you're not building a relationship when you kiss ass.
As a matter of fact,
people are turned off by it.
So you don't want to be that guy.
Hey boss,
what a wonderful meeting.
I got so much out of it.
No,
no,
no.
Put participate and get in the game.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm not saying cause ask cause cause ass isn't going to get you.
It's gonna.
It's gonna look bad.
I mean,
are there some bosses that that feed off of that?
Yes there are and well you gotta you might have to play that game a little bit.
You might have to play the game loop,
not going to feel good.
That's why we have to put our ego in check
and then yeah,
that's what I would do.
So I think you made the right call.
Let's get an go to go to a bunch of these meetings,
see what they're all about and maybe you know,
eventually you're saying,
hey boss,
you know,
these are uncompensated.
We could probably utilize these hours better if we did some this or we did that.
So this is good,
good straight forward method.
I think you made the right call and let us know how it goes.
Yeah,
yeah.
The casinos thing,
everyone knows you're kissing ass and everyone does.
I mean really what you're doing is you're trading your longterm respect.
You're trading that in for that short term popularity with just the boss by the
way,
like all your people,
because your popularity is going down.
Everyone's looking at you like,
look at that guy cause he nas,
look at them.
Even the boss,
even if he likes it,
there's a big part of his brain like all right,
so that's what I'm saying that you don't have to kiss ass right?
You don't have to kiss ass.
But you know what you,
what does the boss want?
Someone that's kissing their ass and saying,
wow,
what a wonderful idea.
Or someone that's actively participate in like a professional,
you know,
that's what they want.
That's what they want to do.
That gotta be done for the cause because they're like,
Dang,
I'm done for the cause.
I'll tell you when I have a problem with something,
I'll tell you why.
You know,
that kind of thing.
But ultimately if you're down for the cause,
your bosses cause heard the whole cause or whatever.
Um,
that's so much of it changes with your attitude if you're to attitude is like,
Oh man,
this is bull.
But if you're on,
she's like,
hey,
this is really cool at the,
that the boss is stepping up.
He's trying to get us engaged in this.
I'm going to go in there and get after it.
That just totally changed your attitude right there.
And I've done that a million times,
played that little game in my head.
Said,
all right,
my boss is an idiot and you know what?
I'm an idiot.
Let's go.
Let's make this happen.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna get after it.
What is,
what stupid things is going to tell me you don't want to do with that stupid
thing he tells me to do.
I'm going to crush it.
I did that at when I was going to officer candidate school.
And there's this thing at officer candidate school where you have to yell
everything that you say.
They call it bean ballistic.
They say you gotta be ballistic at all times and it's pretty cool why they do
it.
Actually they do it because you get some people that are coming in in the
military cause when you go to ocs,
most of the people that are going through ocs with have never been in the
military before.
They're coming from college and they graduated college and now they're going to
ocs.
So they've got 13 weeks to get turned into an officer.
So what they do is they make you yell everything.
Why do they do that?
The reason they make you yell everything is cause there's some people that
aren't confident when they speak.
And so everything that they're gonna say there can be shy about saying it.
Well at ocs you've actually got to yell everything that you say because you
can't go on the bridge of a ship and say,
uh,
can,
can we turn the shift?
You know,
90 degrees to the port?
No,
no,
no.
You have to speak up.
You have to say,
Hey,
we're turning 90 degrees pork.
I don't actually know what the command is cause I wasn't as a surface warfare
officer.
But you know,
you say,
hey,
we're going to turn 90 degrees port.
You can't say it in a timid way.
And so the way they beat that out of used by making you yell every single thing
that you do when you're an officer candidate school.
So what what we did was the upperclassmen that control you when you're going
through,
there's like a class that's getting ready to graduate and they kind of control
you when the drill instructors aren't there.
And so they also make a little money for their fund.
And the way they make money for the Fund is selling Soda and Candy and this
little,
this little closet,
right?
I mean it's,
it's,
it's authorized.
So my class,
I said,
hey guys,
when you go into,
I was the class president w as in can you go?
I said,
where do you go into the Office to Buy Candy or soda?
Which I don't recommend,
but if you do,
if you do,
do it,
go in there and be ballistic.
They were like,
why to go do it because those are the rules.
And so everyone lined up and they went in this little closet and they're yelling
at them.
I would lock on Coca Cola and watch snickers bar.
And after 10 people,
the person that's in there,
the upperclassmen comes out and goes,
you guys are no longer allowed to be ballistic.
And that was the way that we want.
No,
just get it.
I actually did that in bud's to where I'd do stuff to the,
to the extreme,
you know,
like you got to get wet and sandy and buds and which means you got to get jumped
in the ocean,
then roll around in the sand.
Well,
I would jump in the ocean.
I would roll around in the sand and then when you get back to the instructor
that told you to go get wet and Sandy,
you'd have to go back to them and say,
who your instructor Charles,
to make sure that they knew that you got wet and Sandy.
So what I would do is I'd go,
I didn't do it immediately,
but I don't want to figure it out that I could do this.
I did it.
I would go,
I would get wet.
I would get sandy out completely.
I would completely cover my every square inch of my body with sand.
And then I would put sand into my mouth.
I would feel myself,
my mouth is sand and when I'd run up to say who Yada the instructor,
when I'd say who yacht dry sand or come out of my mouth,
it was uh,
it was pretty fun.
So I like to have that attitude like,
oh,
you want to make me do something great,
I'll do it and I'm going to do it with,
with vigor and enthusiasm.
And,
and then we literally in my,
in my buds class when at a certain point they told us we weren't allowed to get
wet and sandy anymore.
They,
they literally told us that.
And uh,
they said no,
you weren't allowed to get wet anymore.
And we were saying what's wrong?
There's no,
you're not allowed on that.
So it actually,
yeah.
Okay,
well headed anyways.
It's kind of like they're,
they're like kind of push pushing you down this hill with insect pest
expectation that you're going to be putting on the brakes to the fire.
Yeah.
So like the more they push it down the hill,
the more your natural tendency hopefully is going to be to put on the brakes.
That's why all that works,
you know,
like,
oh go get wet and said,
aw,
that sucks.
But if you're like,
when sandy time was do this kind of thing,
then it's like,
ah.
And then you,
in a way you can put on the brakes when they say stop and like,
okay,
we want,
I'm going to get witness.
One of my buddies,
we,
so there's something called flights where you run up this hill and you carry
pallets.
You know what a pallet is right there.
I don't know.
They're made of wood or steel.
We had both there.
They call them flights and they actually have a little flight tower.
Just a little drill is called,
it's called flights.
And you put this thing on your back.
So you look like an airplane and you run up this hill and come back down and you
do it as a squad.
And when he'd get back to the,
the bottom,
they'd say,
okay,
who came in last place?
Wait,
how many Kapow let one guy,
one pallet.
Yeah,
one guy per pallet.
And it'd be like,
who?
Okay.
Who came in last place and I'd say,
I came here and then you got to do it again.
But the funniest was when you came back down,
if you were slow or they just wanted to hammer you more than they'd say,
Hey,
you're on fire,
go,
go put it out in.
Which means you got to run then your pallet down to the ocean.
And so,
so one time I came back down and well one time I came back down and I said,
they said you'd have to request permission to land.
And one time I came back down and said,
uh,
I can't land them on fire.
And they go,
okay,
go take a look at the surf.
But what was even better than that was a couple of days later I came back down,
I said,
request permission to touch and go,
which highlights is,
you know,
you,
you land in,
then you take right back off.
So I just,
they go permission.
Granted
it's pretty funny,
isn't it?
Doesn't that cause basically the,
that starts with just embracing the attitude starts with I have a good time with
it.
It doesn't it result in all this crap.
Let's face it.
Men that go get wet.
And Sandy,
I mean from a normal standpoint is allegedly not fun.
So fun.
Neither is the flight bro.
You explained that the flights is not cool but doing it that way it's just as
hard kind of physically.
But it's a little bit the experience,
our terms a little bit harder.
Big spirits is way better though.
And then yeah we put,
we always had a good time when we were doing,
like we used to go on when you're on a ship then you go and the ship do
something called an unwrapped where you,
they load geared,
they load food and supplies and fuel from another ship and we would go help but
we would turn it into like a sport or whatever.
Tried to move as much boxes as we can.
And guys we're all sweating and just getting after it.
And instead of being is,
it'd be in,
cause it's,
it's,
it's whatever.
It's sucks,
right?
Cause you gotta go up there and move a bunch of boxes,
like a moving party basically.
But we actually turn it into a moving party.
Emphasis on party.
We would go out to have fun,
be laughing,
throwing stuff,
and just basically getting after it
labor,
but why not have a good time?
Oh,
that's a good idea.
You got to,
you got to really man up with it for sure.
But once you,
if you can kind of flip that switch,
but that's good.
Yeah,
it changes everything.
When you get that good attitude going,
make it fun.
It's good.
Then those pallets.
Yeah,
flights we waste or we do on quiet Poli.
Holly,
huge beach sand,
you know,
to get to the beach.
Seven Mile Beach,
by the way.
Nice.
Make bonfires with those pallets.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
You can carry them up.
You're back on the truck.
I for sure.
Next question.
Let's do it.
Do you have any recommendations for careers that are similar to the military and
or careers that are based on leadership context here?
The context.
I applied to the Canadian armed forces to be a signals officer and I failed my
medical signals officer.
You know what that is?
Yeah.
It's basically a communications officer.
Right,
right there.
Okay.
So yeah,
currently looking for alternatives.
Well,
I,
I'm not sure what the physical shortfall is.
I'm going to assume that the physical shortfall was something that was
disqualified you from any type of millage.
So maybe you have really bad vision.
Maybe you have really bad hearing it in here.
Maybe you have some irregular heart thing.
Maybe there's just some blood typed,
you know,
did something,
there's a bunch of things that can do that to people and so I'm going to assume
that it was bad enough that you can't join the military at all.
Okay.
The next thing is,
can you get into some kind of police or law enforcement that,
that's the next question because maybe there's something that disqualifies you
from the,
from the military,
but you could still get into police and law enforcement.
And by the way,
if you can't get into that,
what kind of,
maybe some kind of an anti-terror agency that you could possibly go into.
And I would say the next step from there is,
you know,
what kind of an intelligence agency could go walk for,
what kind of a purse,
you know,
it could you be a person that learns a language that learns some technical
skills that allows you to pursue people through the interwebs.
You know,
there's a lot of terror happening on the interwebs and it needs to be stopped.
So who's doing that?
Cyber war.
Cyber wars real.
I mean it's,
it's real.
So is there something that you could presume there?
And guess what?
You're doing it,
you're doing it virtually,
right?
But you're still hunting down terrorists and,
and catching bad guys and preventing terror attacks.
So even though it's not,
you know,
shooting a machine gun,
it's still is a,
he has a huge impact.
And I'll tell you what,
in future,
in the future,
it might even have a bigger impact than the guys that are shooters.
So there's that,
there's that avenue to look at.
And same thing in,
in,
in law enforcement,
there are certain professions that you can get where you're not actually a
police officer,
but you're a a,
you know,
a forensic,
a forensic scientist that goes and looks at crime scenes and tries to figure out
what happens.
So there's definitely some,
some,
uh,
roads to go down there.
Then there's fire fighting.
Of course there's been a paramedic.
That's another good one.
Those are all all service based.
And so that's like a whole group,
right?
That's a whole thing.
Yeah.
And then let's say you can't do any of those things will,
will then what?
Well for me it's really easy.
Construction
software engineering,
being a salesperson,
going into technology,
being a plumber,
being an electrician,
going into automotive,
a prayer or automotive repair.
What?
Like what all those jobs,
if you are getting after those jobs,
they're all you can,
you can excel,
you can own your own company,
you can get after it,
you can lead,
you can make a ton of money.
Any one of those jobs,
Any of them.
If you are a professional and you take pride in your work and you make,
I saw something the other day,
I wish I could find it.
I try and post again,
it was just a,
a plumber had obviously done this massive job where all these pipes were all
coming and going into one thing.
And,
and there was,
you know,
probably 20 or 30 little pieces of pipe,
but they were all perfectly aligned,
perfectly exact in,
and it was in some,
you know,
storage,
a mechanical room.
But it just looked like so professional.
And that's the kind of thing that,
you know,
no matter what your job is,
what are you gonna do?
Are you e all you need to do is step up and get after it.
And all those jobs,
any job that you're doing that your work that you enjoy and you know,
do something that you enjoy and what makes you enjoy things.
To me,
what makes you enjoy,
enjoy things is doing well and practicing and getting good at them and having
pride in your work.
That's awesome.
So I would say,
you know,
you gotta go,
you gotta find something that you like doing and
get after it.
You know,
lot of times
just in general as far as finding what you want to do.
Okay.
You know,
sometimes people like,
Hey,
I like to,
I dunno surf so I'm gonna go be a surf instructor or something like that.
Usually how to find what you want to do doesn't have to do directly.
It's like what are the things that that stimulate you or motivate you or
whatever that that make you like surfing or make you like whatever.
It's like.
So a lot of it is real like basics.
Like I like problem solving this way or something like that.
So tip there is,
look at what you like to or
like what you like.
Don't watch on forensic or whatever.
I like to work with my hands.
Okay,
good.
Then you need to be a carpenter.
You need to be a plumber,
you need to be electrician.
Oh,
I like to work with my brain.
Okay,
you like to solve problems.
Okay.
Become a software engineer where you're trying to figure out how to map all
those things together or a status.
Tisha,
I liked the numbers.
I'm gonna be a stat.
So yes,
absolutely.
What are you interested?
And then what job requires that type of mindset and skill?
Because it's always fun cause I work with so many different companies in every
different industry and whenever I meet,
you know,
there's always a,
a group of people that are just into their job,
right?
They're into it and they want to be the best and it,
and it doesn't matter what it is.
And I've,
I've had,
you know,
I worked with companies,
every different industry and sometimes I think to myself,
well this is a weird industry to kind of,
I kind of,
you know,
just think it's weird that I'm going to work with this particular company
because this is a weird industry.
And then I meet the person that's bringing me in and they're talking to me about
their business.
Like they're going into combat.
Yeah.
Amy.
And I mean that in the most positive way.
They're like,
Hey,
this is what we want to do.
This is our vision right here,
this.
And they're talking about,
you know,
selling shampoo.
I mean,
you know what I mean?
Like just some thing that they're,
that they're into and they just want to do the best that they can at it.
And that becomes a,
a passionate and a fuel.
So it's,
it's,
it's fun to watch,
it's fun to watch and it doesn't,
and it translates,
you know,
the attitude that they bring to it and the leadership that they bring to it
translates into their whole life.
That's how well,
that's what makes people successful in business in life is when there they bring
that attitude of I'm going to,
I'm going to do this the best of my ability and I'm gonna grow and we get
better.
And I'm a find my weaknesses and I'm gonna work on those.
And the next thing you know,
these people owning their own businesses and it's awesome.
No.
Next question,
let's do that.
Why do you never or rarely swear or for,
well,
I did.
He never spend,
anyway,
that's part a of the question.
Why do you never swear or used profanity?
B Part B of the question is what do you do to combat burnout?
This,
my schedule isn't helping.
I'm a prosecutor,
constantly overrun with violence and despair up up at 5:00 AM to play music or
read that you did to purple belt.
Trying to keep up with the monster,
the young monsters on the mat but never seemed to have enough time because life
is always making huge demands and trying to get better at gymnastic strength
training without neglecting my wife and my dog.
Thanks for encouraging us.
Regular photos deep.
Dig a little deeper and try a little harder.
Well
the swearing question,
we actually talked about that already on one of the earlier podcasts.
I don't know which number.
Yeah,
but it's covered in great detail.
I think it's an 18 minute conversation.
Let's not rehash that one.
And just to clarify,
clarify that a more appropriate.
We'll just say the question would be to modify to say why do you never or rarely
swear on while you're recording?
That is true cause you get your swear on from time to time I,
well no I have used,
I give myself a six foul language usages per month doing outside,
you know,
outside recording.
Yeah.
No,
I'm just kidding.
I do swear.
I think it's,
I think [inaudible] so cool.
I don't know if it's cool or not,
but I do do it,
but I don't square here and I don't square or when I'm presenting and I don't
swear in front of my wife and kids and I really got in front of your wife.
Not Really,
let's say that's bad enough,
but that's not really sure.
I mean I try and give her some respect and treat,
you know,
speak.
In fact,
when I do swear in front of her,
I do it knowingly that I'm trying to make some kind of a,
a statement about something that really emphasize on thing.
Okay,
cool man.
That's good.
Okay.
Now let's get to the combating burnout.
First of all,
it sounds like,
uh,
this guy right here has a lot going on,
which is awesome.
Good for you.
Yeah,
that's killer.
Welcome to life.
Right now.
A couple of things,
right?
And I guess this might be a little bit of a theme tonight,
but you gotta make it fun,
right?
Instead of viewing these things like an oppressive grind.
I mean,
just the way that,
you know,
at the maths,
like on the mats,
I don't have time and life is making huge demands and I'm trying just to make,
try to do just gymnastic strength training,
but without neglecting my wife.
And it's like everything's a grind.
No,
it's not.
You have the opportunity.
Did you gymnasts,
you've got a wife and you've got a dog.
So that's,
that's,
that's awesome.
As Echo would say,
that's dope right there.
So what,
you know,
instead of looking at him like that,
let's look at them at what we can do to get more done.
Okay.
First of all,
what kind of time constraints can you put on things?
Right.
Force yourself to do some things faster.
Okay.
Um,
for instance,
reading first thing in the morning.
I don't know,
I don't agree with that.
Like why would you get up in the morning and read reading?
No,
end of the day.
Okay.
Playing music first thing in the morning.
Playing music should be fun and enjoyable as should be.
So getting up and going,
okay,
I'm going to go play music.
You're turning it into a labor,
right?
You're turning it into a labor.
It should be something that's down.
Why winding you down at the end of the night.
So when you wake up in the morning,
do something that requires some discipline and and has you get after it a little
bit and wakes you up a little bit more.
Right.
Um,
you know,
another thing is,
Jujitsu,
how,
this is a weird question,
how fast can you train Jujitsu because I can tell you for many,
many years and also what part did you did to,
is important to you in what part of you getting the most out of cause for many,
many years,
especially once the war started,
when I would show up to train basically at the,
at the end of class,
and I still do this sometimes I show up when Dean has done teaching,
when Jeff has done teaching,
believe me,
if I had unlimited hours,
I would sit there and absorb everything that they have to say.
I learned something from Dean the other day.
I couldn't believe it.
I couldn't believe what I learned from Dean the other day.
I couldn't believe that I didn't know it.
I couldn't believe that.
I didn't know it.
I couldn't believe how well it worked.
And I couldn't believe that that bastard never taught it to me,
which made me really angry.
But that's the way it is.
I've been training for 20 years and he taught me a basic fundamental thing that
I did not know.
So if I could,
I'd of course I'd be in there all the time,
you know,
learning,
absorbing Glover's the same way Glover teaches you little things.
And he goes,
Oh,
you should do this right here.
Go God man,
how did I not know that?
So I would learn all I could,
but I don't know if it's time,
time for that.
So what I do show up when that stuff's over,
can I go on a train,
get it on and
how fast does it,
so I'm saying is how fast can you,
what,
what gets you the most impact in the shortest amount of time?
So for me,
it's all I always feel if I don't have time to take an hour and a half class,
that's,
you know,
a 10 minute warm up,
uh,
30 minutes or 40 minutes of instruction to 10 minutes,
20 minutes of his drilling and then half an hour of rolling or however long that
I'll put together his,
but,
but I'm going to show up.
For me,
the most important part at this juncture in my Jujitsu career is the rolling.
So I'm going to show up for that last,
you know,
40 minutes,
45 minutes.
I'm gonna get my rounds in.
Maybe that's what you need to do,
cause you can't,
you don't have time to take an hour and a half class with all that other stuff.
So see if you can do that.
The other thing you might have to do is prioritize and execute the,
uh,
the,
the extra,
extra curricular activities,
right?
What you got gymnastic alone,
you've got BJ going on,
you've got reading,
you've got music going on.
How do you,
um,
how do you bring those things together or how do you prioritize them so that you
are,
you focus on which one's going to be the most important?
That's the bottom line,
right?
Because you might not have time to do everything and so you might be just
dabbling in all of them and not making any progress in any of them.
So that's not good.
Another thing,
how can you manipulate your work schedule,
right?
What can you do at your work schedule that you could squeeze something in?
For instance,
do people take a lunch break?
Do people take a lunch break?
I haven't taken lunch in the,
in the seal teams.
I didn't take lunch,
you know,
in,
why would you take lunch?
Like,
Oh,
I'm going to go for an hour of time and go to a place and sit down and eat.
No,
I'm gonna eat at my desk while I'm working,
so I'm never going to take lunch.
So maybe during your work people are,
you know,
people,
hey,
we're going to go down and some lunch.
Cool.
That's what I'm going to go do.
You know,
500 burpees or whatever,
we go run to the gym real quick and get a workout in everybody,
my sprints or whatever.
So she what?
What can you do?
There may be,
maybe you could get more work done in this time when you're waking up or leaks,
you want to get after it.
Maybe that's the time when you should go to the job because no one's going to
bother you.
You can get a bunch of work done and then you can take a break from,
from seven until nine when the rest of the coming in with their coffee and want
to talk to,
you know,
that's when you're working out or that's when you're doing something else.
So how can you maximize it?
I used to do this when I'm,
we used to have to write evaluations for all of our guys and it's a big pain in
the navy and they have to be perfect and they're getting recording guys record.
So you want to be perfect.
You want to take the Africa,
this is how the guys get evaluated so they can get advanced.
So you want to take your time with it.
But during,
during we'd get,
you know,
I was in charge,
I get these big stacks of evils I'd have to go through and it's corrected some
basically doing corrections of papers over and over and over again until they're
perfect and it's meticulous work.
And so what I would do is during that time period,
it would take like a month to get it done.
I wouldn't work out first thing in the morning.
I would go to work immediately in the morning and while everyone else was either
not there or I would work,
I would work.
And then when everyone showed up,
you know,
at 11 I'd go work out during lunch and just,
if you want to come talk to me because everyone always wants to talk to you.
Right.
So I'm going to say to you again,
just leave me alone cause I'm trying to work,
but maybe you,
so how can you manipulate your work to,
to maximize what you're getting out of it.
Another thing is maybe take a little break from some of the activities.
Maybe take a break from music,
maybe take a break from,
or maybe you say,
Oh,
you know what?
I've been doing an hour of music a day.
You don't want to change that.
I'm going to do for the next month.
I'm only going to do 15 minutes just to keep my,
keep my skills maintained,
but I'm not going to progress and progress and I understand that.
And or maybe you take a break from the mats for two weeks.
I can tell you if you're training every day,
a two week break from the mat in many cases myself,
definitely I take a jump up,
I get better if I take a break.
That's why I travel.
For me,
I don't like it when it goes on all the time,
but I go away for six days and don't train.
I come back and I feel a little bit better.
I have some stuff gels in the brain,
so
yeah,
I have no problem.
That used to make dean one time a kid one on one time.
I came home from deployment and Dina and I were training and I was just so fired
up,
you know,
coming and I was kind of smashing him and I'm yelling at him,
I've been on deployment,
I've been overseas,
what have you been doing back here?
Outcome,
I'm crushing you,
blah,
blah.
And just crushing him that day.
And so he went home that night and he made us is when he had to burn.
This is when you had to burn cds.
He made it,
he made a CD that was called killed Jocko.
That was all of his favorite,
whatever metal songs.
Then he came back and the next day he came back and destroyed me.
So yeah,
he did kill Jocko that next.
But uh,
yeah,
so taking a break sometime just to,
just to focus on some of the other stuff.
The other thing,
okay,
you got your wife and your dog.
I spend time with them while you're doing these activities.
Right.
Your dog can go running with you.
That's awesome.
Your dog and come to park.
Watch.
You do pull ups,
right?
Your dog can chase the Kettlebell that you're,
that you're throwing or whatever the,
the,
the shot put or the medicine ball you can,
you can have,
be careful if you're throwing your candle dog cause might've been bad.
Bad Advice.
You feel kettle bells.
I was still,
I was with my buddy,
we were in New Jersey one time and we went through cattle bells.
It was wintertime and we were throwing kettlebells in the kettlebells would get,
it was part of the workout was you had to dig the Kettlebell backup,
the mud.
It was pretty funny.
Anyways,
so what my point would say that if you threw your kettlebell and it hit a dog,
it would not be good.
So don't do that one.
But take your dog with you to the park.
Go have fun.
Hang out.
And same thing with your wife.
You know what?
Your wife doesn't want to do some Jujitsu.
My wife did Jujitsu before she was pregnant,
so when she was coming to the gym with me all the time,
she was training and then you're just,
let's bring it into the family a little bit.
Get her in.
She gymnastics.
Get your Tim Ferris Acro Yoga on with with your girl,
right.
That's the same thing.
Get her in the game,
have her lay down some vocal tracks.
Right.
To get me a little backing vocals from Mama.
Let's hear what that sounds like and that way you're doing the stuff that you
want to do,
what you're bringing your family into the game a little bit.
And like I said,
man,
I have fun because all these things that you're talking about,
even being a prosecutor,
which I'm sure like you said in beds you and just violence and disturbing things
all the time and it's a challenging job.
But,
but enjoy that challenge and how can you do a better and how can you win,
you know,
I'm going to have fun with it.
And I had fun all the time.
I had fun overseas,
I had fun in Iraq,
I had fun on the,
in the bowels of a ship while I was deployed on for six months.
I'm going to have fun and laugh hysterically at things.
And it's the same thing with the music and with working out and Jujitsu and you
got to,
you got to enjoy them all.
And just like when you're on the mat,
you're competing against these young monsters.
And we just try and compete with everybody.
Just try and get better
cause that is winning.
And that's what's gonna make you better in the long run.
Cause that'll make you stick with things,
make you stick with them.
Because if you don't enjoy Jujitsu,
why would you do it for 25 years?
Or if you don't enjoy music,
why would you keep practicing it?
So my final thought on this man,
my brother have some fun with this stuff.
Yeah.
The Dang and being a prosecutor,
that's the kind of job where even when you go home,
probably it's still in your mind,
you know?
So
as far as the whole experience,
it's like,
Dang,
this is,
my job is taking up so much time.
It's true.
So yeah,
I would imagine that would make it more of an like a difficult thing to balance.
Figuring out that way to leave your job,
leave your job at work.
Yeah.
Right.
We want to excel at it.
I just had this conversation with a guy today just because if you're looking at
your you,
you can't,
the way you're going to do your job better as a prosecutor is not by just being
100% focused on that 100% of the time.
You will not do a better job,
right?
If you do good job,
if you focus on that a lot and you still do Jujitsu and you still train and you
still get after it,
you still you that.
How many good ideas?
I have so many good ideas that come to me when I'm working out when I'm doing
yard work because you've got to get,
you've got to give your brain a little space to think.
It's just like planning a seal operation.
If you're sitting there looking at the map from two inches away the whole day
trying to get this plan perfect,
you're not going to see everything and it's the same thing with any job that you
have.
If you get yourself totally wrapped around that job,
you're not going to have the PR,
the proper detachment from the job to see the bigger picture.
So you must get some space between you and your job so you can think properly.
Yeah.
And just like,
and that other element,
like everything you do,
studying,
working out,
it's like this where you,
you've worked hard,
you get your reps and then you get your rest.
You can't be doing push ups all day every single day.
You know,
you won't get stronger actually.
Yeah.
Right.
So when you know,
just like studying where they say like,
I guess when you study or memorize and,
or both,
whatever.
And then you go to sleep,
that's when they get your neural connections get solidified.
Gets the,
yeah.
When you sleep,
that's not when you're studying.
So if you're cramming for a test for two days straight,
no sleeping,
you know,
that won't help you as much as sunny for four hours properly getting some good
sleep,
get your rest.
Yeah.
So that's the same thing with the job.
You know,
get grind on the job and then men forget about it for a little bit.
When you come back,
it'll make me better put the same.
It's,
it's weird.
Uh,
coincidentally,
that's what I just said happens at Jitsu.
Exactly right.
Just so you know.
And a little tip in,
on and off this would it,
I know this because I know how that feels when you're like,
Dang,
I've,
I work so much and I don't have time to go work out or whatever,
or I'm always pressed for time or whatever.
You can kind of overlap the two.
So what I did,
I'd go to work and then right after work I'd go home,
had changed,
and then I'd go to the gym and then I'd be like,
man,
I don't have time for anything.
If I expect to workout as much as I need to in my mind or as much as I want,
I kind of have time for anything else.
But she was,
I think you kind of do have time when you start to overlap.
So,
and this is sounding real obvious and simple,
but sometimes you kind of,
you miss these little things.
So what I ended up doing,
which a lot of people do,
is they'll just,
you just bring your workout clothes and your preworkout to the,
to work,
to work and then go straight to the gym.
You saved yourself all kinds of time.
You said you actually got your workout,
you saved 40 minutes just by doing that.
That was your workout.
And,
and that's not to mention you,
when you go home,
a lot of time,
you have this a lot of times at subconscious to it so that you start to just
mellow out.
So the chance of you skipping a workout becomes site.
That's a,
that's a different thing for sure.
But um,
that seems like an obvious thing,
you know,
like,
yeah,
bring your,
if you're going to work out afterwards,
it seems obvious.
I know,
but
there's other things just like that in like life or let me just overlap them.
Eating lunch at your desk.
Same exact things.
Just straight up efficiency.
Yeah.
To do a whole podcast on just how to be more efficient.
So if you're keeping your eyes open for,
okay,
how can I little overlap here or up there and you'd be like,
aw Dang,
I got two hours at the end of the day right now.
Or just more time to do more stuff,
you know.
So just keep your eyes open man.
And the Jujitsu thing too.
Back to the real quick,
the um,
you said try to focus on like the parts that,
that help you the most.
Like come in,
you know,
don't quote unquote for lack of a better term or waste your time on like the
warm up and you know,
if that's not where you get the most learning before you do that,
clear it with the instructor instruct.
They don't dig it when you just skip the warm up rolling in when it's time to
roll this like a thing.
So you've got to,
you got to say like a lot,
like I'll do that too to your instructor and say,
Hey,
I'm working a bunch right now.
I got this case going on and I got to get through it.
And so I'm only to come three times a week and all I have time for just to come
in and roll.
Is that cool with you?
Yeah.
What are they going to say?
No.
Yeah,
or just say at this time,
because if you say I can only have time to roll,
they're like,
oh you want to skip my lesson?
Then that's the part he chose to skip.
So you can say,
Hey,
I can only come in at this time.
Well I've been in that situation where,
you know,
I've been working on this thing and also other schedules.
I had my new baby and all this stuff.
So it's like Dang,
the only time I can come in realistically,
um,
was that to get there at like 1235 just to get your role in?
Yeah.
When you know the one that led the instruction starts at noon and then I,
I know Jeff was like,
you know how your bill thinks he can just real,
I don't know if he thought this or not.
It's probably me being,
I felt,
but it could have been me being paranoid.
Greg encourages that by the way.
Great chain.
He encourages.
If you get more out of just rolling,
then you do the lesson.
Like when you get to a certain belt and you're,
you know how you're learning starts to take shape.
Like what you learn better,
he encourages it.
But the only thing is that just saying what I just learned from Dean the other
day and how,
what other things have I missed?
Yeah.
But you know what I mean?
But that's an opportunity,
cost situation,
you know,
Dang cause important stuff.
But
I always,
uh,
like even if I'm,
if I get there a little late,
I'll be like,
I'll look and see what moves they showed and,
and I'll,
and I'll figure it out if there's anything I didn't know.
Yeah.
But how can you figure out if there's something you didn't know?
No,
because I say,
hey man,
what'd you teach today?
Or I'll watch guys,
what'd you guys do?
What'd you guys go over today?
And that's all this.
And I'll go,
Hey Jeff,
how does that work?
Or I'll say,
hey dean,
what's this thing here?
So I'll just ask him,
you know,
basically reteach the whole class.
No,
not reached cause he,
cause like you just said,
my learning is developed.
So all they need to say is,
hey,
we went over this escape right here and we went over this finish and here's how
you do it or this transition.
Right.
So,
but that one,
yeah.
You got to kind of communicate Spec,
respect had Spec your instruction.
We'll ha yeah,
totally.
Got It.
Next question.
I've encountered an issue in the workplace I've never dealt with before.
I'm a former Air Force Sto.
Sdl.
Yup.
This is like a combat controller.
They call in,
they call in aircraft.
They set up,
they call for fire,
they set up,
uh,
they set up air strips and a field.
Really cool job.
Okay.
As it says there,
or as you may affect an lean,
know us as combat control.
Okay.
I'm not civilian mechanical engineer.
Dang big up in the oil and gas industry through attrition.
The people I work closely with have learned a little about what it is I used to
do.
I'm treated noticeably different as a result.
For example,
some refer to me as Mr Esef.
Now my current approach is just to laugh it off and ignore it.
But how can I respectfully indicate that when I'm in the office,
I'm not that anymore and no different than anyone else.
Well,
I think you're taking the right approach and that is to ignore it.
Um,
I think there's probably something about your history,
right,
that people get a little bit either intimidated or comfortable with in some way
because they think all of a sudden,
you know,
you're,
you're this different type of thing.
But I think it is definitely something where at well,
in the seal teams,
the minute you say,
Hey,
don't call me that,
like people,
that's what we asked you,
your nickname for life,
if you say that.
So,
you know,
I think we know for one thing,
it sounds like you're not referring back to your time in the service on the a
lot.
But another thing is don't,
a subtle thing is don't answer to,
you know,
Mr Esef just don't answer.
They're not saying you have to be a jerk about it.
But if someone says Miss Mr Esef,
hey Mr Esef and just like keep doing what you're doing until,
and so don't reinforce that that's what they should call you,
right?
That's just like a basic,
a basic thing.
But I think you're doing the right thing.
And I mean,
if you ever wanted to say something about it again,
the minute you say something about it,
now all of a sudden it turns into a big deal.
Now people are whispering like he doesn't like to talk about it.
So now we're in that situation.
So man,
just ignore it.
Keep working.
And I mean,
carry on with your,
with your mission,
with these,
with these guys and the gas and there's a bunch of veterans and a gas,
oil industry.
I'm in the,
there.
Did you know,
um,
when,
when we work with gas,
oil was a lead.
A bunch of vets.
Maybe that's more on the front line troopers.
But man,
I met a bunch of,
no,
a bunch of veterans.
Um,
so I don't know,
maybe,
maybe they,
maybe they saw a little,
a little reaction they got from you.
So let's make sure we're not doing that.
Just ignore it and carry on the best thing you can do right in no,
in the seal teams,
if somebody does something that annoys you,
do not show it.
Same thing with my family,
with my kids,
man.
When my kids figure out that something annoys one of my other kids and they just
were relentless annihilation with that,
whatever that thing is.
And I did that when I was a kid.
I was,
you know,
my sisters and I,
we were so mean to each other on whatever.
And that's sort of,
I dunno,
I guess that's sort of a tradition in my family is,
you know,
um,
it's sort of a tradition is of no emotional mercy,
right?
If you find something,
you're just going to grind on it and that's the way,
that's the way it works.
And also no credit,
no credit will be given.
There's no credit will be given you.
This is like,
oh,
oh yeah,
whatever.
So,
uh,
but yeah,
man,
ignore it.
They'll get over it.
Kind of like on heart.
Remember the Lionheart when he's like the Van Damme Movie Man.
Anyway,
he goes into the final thing against the big guy should do it.
Another podcast without me.
When you talk about cheesy movies,
I'm telling you to say,
it doesn't matter that movie tooth,
you're not,
it's the exact same concept,
but you can't show it.
So he goes in broken rape,
all the money's on the table,
whatever.
Broken Rib.
He's like,
he gets hit in the rear.
Well no,
he doesn't get hit in the ribs.
He like,
he goes to him and there were any flinches like all quick.
And the guy,
the big guy,
he's fighting goes boom,
he flinches I'll quick.
And he goes,
see what I'm saying?
Hmm.
Nope.
Good.
Is it ever,
okay,
so next question.
Next question.
Yeah,
sure.
All right.
This is just my question and I'm busting out in the middle of it.
Last one.
Okay.
Yeah.
Is it ever okay to violate core values to achieve a goal?
Okay.
So first of all,
really obvious your values and your goals should be aligned.
They should not be adversarial,
they shouldn't be countered to each other.
And if you think about what your goals are,
your goals should be set up in a way that they support your values and vice
versa.
That's just the way it is.
So I'm not sure where this is going to be an issue.
If you're setting up goals that are contrary to your values,
you've got some issues.
Now I guess if you had the goal of winning the Blue Blue Belt Jujitsu
championships,
and in order to win you,
you cheated.
Like you claim someone was reaping your leg and use it.
Oh,
you tap and you get the guide to qualify it and you win.
That's could be an example right now.
Do I support that?
No.
You know,
that's wrong.
You,
you go win against the values of actually the values of martial arts to do that.
So you didn't win anything and you didn't achieve your goal because weren't
actually the best.
So I say no on that one.
Uh,
another one.
Let's say you wanted to make a certain level of profit at your company.
Yeah.
So you cheated a little bit on the quality of the manufacturing and you sold
items that weren't quite reliable.
Do I support that?
No.
Right.
For annual.
And why?
Let me tell you why.
Because your goal,
your goal is not even aligned with your goal itself.
Because when you start making substandard manufactured items,
what's going to happen in the long run,
people are going to say,
we don't like these.
Yeah,
we're not going to buy him anymore.
So you didn't win.
You might've wanted the short term,
but you didn't win in.
And again,
you're going against your value.
You should have values that you don't want to.
Hmm.
You know,
take profit over making good product.
And again,
in the long run,
that value is going to cost you.
Right.
People aren't going to want to buy your product anymore.
Okay.
Another one I could think of,
like let's say your goal was to lose weight or to gain weight or whatever,
some kind of positive physical change.
Answer.
You're working hard,
but then you decide you're going to jump on steroids,
right?
You're gonna jump on steroids and,
and you get that goal,
right?
Because steroids are a huge advantage.
But again,
I say no because if you can think about what your goal is,
like why are you trying to gain weight or lose weight?
Your goal is to,
is to be healthy,
right?
That's your value as you value your health.
And so when the minute you start doing something that's countered your health,
well that's not,
that's not helping your longterm.
It's your value is not aligned with your goal and your goal is not aligned with
your value.
So get them lined up.
Mm.
So now might we at some point compromise our values,
compromise our values to reach a goal?
I think that changes the answer a little bit,
right?
We might compromise.
You remember that question that we had about the people that are snakes and how
do you work with them?
You're eight.
You know,
should you work with someone that's dishonest or backstabbing,
but there are a cog in the machine of your team and your values right?
They might beat a,
call the person out and say,
hey,
you're a,
you're a backstabber and I don't want to work with you that that might be what
your values tell you to do,
but your goal end.
If you do that,
first of all,
you don't progress.
You don't,
your team doesn't work better together.
They work worse together.
And so in the long run you don't win because you stuck hardcore with your
values.
And by the way,
if you stick with your,
if you,
if you bend your values,
you compromise your values a little bit to get through this transitional period.
Now you get promoted,
now you get a situation where you can fire that person.
That's a backstabber.
So you,
you have to compromise your values as a personal little bit.
And you know,
there's the enemy of my enemy is my friend,
right?
The enemy of my enemy is my friend.
So you might compromise your values short term working somebody that you're not
totally aligned with value wise.
And again,
if you're going to get the long term strategic goal,
well then maybe it's worth it because going to put you in a position where you
can then hold your values better if from a,
from a senior position or from a more powerful position.
So you might compromise them a little bit.
Again,
these are small compromises and you should have things.
Of course,
we got things that values that you're,
you're never going to compromise on,
right?
I'm hitting a girl,
you know?
Right.
You should,
you should never hit a girl,
right.
Never hit a woman.
Now that being said,
if there's a woman that's about to do something truly evil,
you know,
kill a child or some kind of a terrorist act,
and the only thing you have that you can stop it is to hit her.
Well,
guess what?
She's getting hit.
You know what I mean?
So even then,
your value of never hitting a girl can be compromised momentarily while you stop
a child from being murdered or whatever.
Um,
do you know,
we,
as we hold a value of,
we always want to tell the truth.
Mm.
But if you had a,
an extreme example,
if you had some kind of a state secret and,
and you got captured,
well of course you might lie about that and there's little,
I mean we could get into a whole like white lie discussion on stuff like when
your wife asks you how's the chicken and you want to tell her it's the most dry
and,
and charcoal tasting item that you've ever put in your mouth,
that's not going to help you long term.
So I might,
I might compromise my values of being truthful and tell her it's pretty good.
Can I have some more ketchup over here?
Can I get some more barbecue sauce?
All this catch up on chicken and know and I'm going to go grab some more water.
Would you like to say?
So I might compromise my values a little bit there.
Uh,
so
I guess what I'm saying is,
and people,
this is the thing people probably what they think of my persona because people
will think,
oh,
on Charles was going to be this uncompromising,
never settle,
allow no slack kind of person.
Right?
That's when people want it.
Want,
you know,
want,
I guess want to see me as,
but the reality is reason,
reason and thought.
Hmm.
Can,
can override values for the right reasons.
And that's why we can think,
that's why we can think of there's,
there's actually times,
there's actually times we'd holding your values goes against your values.
So if yours backup your friends,
right?
You always back up your friends,
but then your friend does something that's totally immoral and is against your
values.
Well then you can't back up and you can't hold the value of backing up your
friends because guess what?
They did something immoral.
They did something that was wrong.
And so if you held your values,
you'd be not holding your values.
That's the dichotomy there,
right?
That's the dichotomy that,
and the additional dichotomy is you hold your values,
right?
You hold to those basic principles that you believe in,
but at the same time,
you've got to apply logic and reason to them to make sure that they are
supporting your longterm goal and your long term values.
Cause you don't wanna,
you don't want to make a hard stand on something that costs you everything.
We're now in the future.
You can no longer manipulate anymore situations.
That's one of the things that makes leadership and and life heart is that it
isn't black and white.
It isn't black and white.
It's gray in.
So our decisions on these very things,
these are the challenges of leadership
and there's,
there's no way right or wrong answer of,
of saying if it's right or wrong to violate your,
your values to achieve a goal.
That initial questions,
there's too many variables in that.
There's too many variables.
But start with this part that I started the whole answer with.
Align your values with your goal.
That's where you start.
And then you use reason
[inaudible] and fought to determine your actions based on the situation weighed
against your values.
You have to think.
Yeah.
So given what you're saying,
yes.
So it's less like just values.
Like you have a dinner plate with here's my values kind of thing.
It's more of a hierarchy of values.
So you will violate your values if it's on,
you know,
level two for a level four,
you know what I mean?
Like all hit all knock a girl right out.
If it's in the way of my higher value,
which is protect your family,
protect my family,
kids and all this stuff.
Same thing with girls.
Don't mess ladies out there.
Don't mess with that.
Goes family.
Please don't come in at you.
You know,
obviously same thing with you know,
the writing on your or backing up your friend.
Yeah.
You know,
my values back into my friend that's level two.
the whole air moral thing,
assaulting a girl,
I don't know.
Whatever the,
you know,
that's level four.
So sorry.
Number two,
you know,
I'm going for number four,
kindness.
So it was like a higher,
yeah,
you got a little hierarchy.
Values.
There's some,
you know,
obviously there's some that I can't eat.
You know,
you could give any of one of your highest values that you could come up with and
you could sit here and,
and theoretically come up with a situation where you would sacrifice that value
and that's fire.
That's just the way it is.
Yeah.
So that's why we're humans.
We have the ability to think,
we have the ability to reason and sometimes you might have to compromise your
values a little bit to who will survive to survive and get so that you can long
term
carry out your values to a higher degree.
Yeah.
Like the um,
back to the people want to lose weight,
you know,
if usually people who,
I don't know,
I guess I would imagine that usually people who take steroids,
their value isn't the health.
It's like,
cause people did typically,
unless it's a medical thing point,
you know,
the story would think for Allie it's for to win or to cool.
Yeah.
Which is kind of strange,
but you know,
it's usually to win a competition or something like this.
But um,
but nonetheless,
I think that holds true given what you said.
And I think it's kind of kind of coming together there.
I think that it is like a hierarchy of values.
Yeah.
And if someone's going to use steroids to cheat,
that's,
I mean even that we could,
it's a whole nother discussion.
But what do they really proving?
One of they really winning,
right?
Yeah.
And that goes back to remember,
uh,
I forget what we were talking about.
Like some people like they want to,
they want to,
they want to appear to win.
You know,
especially now you can see it on like online that you don't spend that much time
just cruising Facebook,
but you see,
you can see someone that,
you know,
I don't know.
They're there.
They're about to murder each other.
Husband and wife,
they hate each other.
They don't even sleep in the same room,
but they went on vacation with their kids or whatever and they're like,
oh,
so in love in front of the Ferris wheel or the waterfall or whatever.
And you're like,
Bro,
you just want people to think you when you just want to up here.
That one,
you know,
but it's not real.
That's why people cheat.
Yeah.
That's what I liked.
The guy that you get to thing when they're like,
okay,
I'm going to,
I'm going to say,
this guy read my leg,
I'm gonna tap.
Oh,
he's Dq.
You can't do that.
But you know,
you cheated kind of thing.
He,
his goal wasn't to win,
it was just to get the metal.
So it's,
you know,
well he's getting,
the metal is damp here,
but he's just,
he doesn't have the proper values actually be the winner.
He needs to check his values.
He needs to check his hierarchy of values.
Yeah.
So he didn't want to actually,
when you wanted the metal tube here that he want kind of thing.
Next question.
Is there any way to recalibrate the flight or fight response?
I get that x,
I get that access in adrenaline.
Oh,
I get that.
Accessing adrenaline.
That gives me the wobbly legs and the flight response.
How do I go about remapping my reaction?
Well,
absolutely.
Um,
and I'm not 100% sure what situations you're talking about,
but any type of danger,
right.
Gives you this flight or fight response.
So train starts with training,
Jujitsu,
boxing,
Muay Thai,
wrestling,
shooting,
competing,
right.
You get used to those butterflies when you compete,
you get those butterflies and you get used to him and so train.
Yeah.
And get used to seeing how that reaction,
what that adrenaline feels like and,
and also get used to understanding what the superior action is.
Right.
Fight or flight.
Cause sometimes flight is the correct response.
Sometimes fight is the correct response.
But what you want to do is you want to be able to assess and dictate which
response you're going to give and not just do whatever your instinct tells you.
Cause sometimes your instinct might be wrong.
And so again,
I don't know what your actually your,
the,
the situation where you're going into,
but whatever it is,
cause people get the fight or flight response to,
to everyday things to like public speaking,
right?
Oh yeah.
Rock climbing.
Um,
and that's why I say do you know,
do these things,
training them.
So public speaking,
rock climbing,
you know,
if you want to get good at rock block,
like you want to get over that fight or flight response.
When you get up,
go go rock climbing.
You'll use to it.
You scared of heights,
go start parachuting.
You know,
you'll get used to it.
You're scared of the water.
Get worked up and go through swimming and then GIM,
come scuba certified.
Just the things that you're not comfortable with.
Get comfortable with being uncomfortable.
Yeah.
While you're doing them too,
while you're doing them,
pay attention.
You got to detach a little bit.
When these things are,
when you're training,
detach a little bit and see what is going on your mindset.
See what red flags that you can see,
what things will make you aware of the fact that your nerves or your adrenalin
and you're,
you're,
you feel yourself clenching your fist,
you know?
Okay.
So cuts my fist.
Be Aware of it so that you can change it so you can adjust it and put yourself
again,
put yourself into these scenarios and escalate them so they get harder and
harder and harder and worse and worse and worse until you're,
until you start to get control of these things.
Okay.
Here's something weird and they,
it's not weird.
You're not going to think this is weird,
but um,
what I used to get super nervous about fight or flight response,
it was public street,
right?
Yeah.
But that,
that's not worse than that.
That's not the story.
No,
not worth necessarily,
but just a different thing is like confrontation,
you know,
like like hey know whether someone's confronting me or someone or I got to
confront someone,
you know it's like this barrier.
Yup.
You know some people they'll just step back and forth that Barry,
they'll confront you and then go back to just be like,
all right,
I'm going to go back to work kind of thing or school,
whatever.
But man,
I've always seen it when I was younger or whatever as this barrier.
Then it's like
you don't cross it until it's 100% go time.
So anytime I'm close to the barriers,
like you get super nervous because it's like Dang,
is this confrontation mean physical fighting or just in general physical injury.
Anything.
Like if something happened with somebody who we're working with and they lost
something and you had to go confront him on it,
you that would make you get a fight or flight.
You know how we're just cruising,
you know,
fully
and let's say Menier Cruisey I'm saying chocolate and I'm teasing you about
something and then you liked didn't like something and then he got it went from
like this to like,
you know what I mean?
Like you didn't like what I said or something and you're like,
hey,
I didn't like that.
And it became this thing like,
okay,
yeah,
yeah.
For what in it's that it's the,
I can be cruising,
I can be on good terms with someone once it goes bad,
it's like,
to me,
I just looked at it as this just this huge barrier that,
so I,
I actually,
I actually get something like that and for me what it is,
same thing.
But when,
as soon as I feel it,
you know what I do,
I go like,
I go,
if I,
I just default because,
and it sometimes what bothers me sometimes,
you know,
you don't always have the opportunity.
Like let's say I get an email,
someone says,
hey,
I really didn't like the way this happened and blah,
blah blah.
It'll bother me.
And especially it will bother me if someone will say,
Hey,
when for instance,
this is the kind of thing that would bother me if someone says,
Hey,
you did this.
It seemed like you know,
you are putting me down in front of all these people.
I would feel bad about it.
Right.
And I'd be like,
it would dry.
And so the only way for me to get over it is I want to talk to them and say,
hey man,
this is what I did.
I'm going to send out an email to everyone to make sure that they know that that
was,
you know,
my wasn't mine.
Don't,
you know,
say that you did a great job or whatever,
just try and make it right.
But the only,
all otherwise it just turns,
it burns me up and I have to confront it.
I the,
the thing that bothers me,
and I used to like,
I recognize this now when I was younger,
I might not recognize it.
I would just sit there and I wouldn't know what to do.
But now I know the solution,
the solution is when something's bothering you,
you go and you address the problem.
You know,
like my,
my kids will do something and I'll,
I'll be all angry about it and I just go,
oh,
what do I need to do is go and talk to them about it.
Hey,
what did you,
what are you doing?
Why did you do this?
Here's the impact it has on the family.
Here's the impact it has on your life.
Here's some other opportunities that you might miss out.
Now here's some things that you could do better,
or whatever.
You know,
here's some corrective actions we can take.
Whatever.
The worst thing I can do is just sit there and hold it inside.
No,
not a good thing to do.
Yeah.
And I knew that fully.
I mean that,
that it's not a good thing to do,
but it was just one of the things that,
that really induced that fight or flight response.
And the strange thing,
you know what helped a lot,
even just in regular confrontation,
any it,
it's a specific type of confrontation is not the kind where
you know how like you,
you say something then you leave and then you think back on,
wait,
did I insult him?
Bothers me,
but that to me I'll call you right now.
Okay.
I said that's no problem.
The kind of its own,
the only kind of stuff,
the or the only stuff that did it was stuff that to cross this line puts us on
bad terms temporarily or permanently.
It puts us on like not good terms anyway.
It was that kind of thing.
But unless,
you know what totally helped was Jujitsu totally helped where I still don't want
to,
but if I think that the competition has to go down for whatever reason,
it's just way easier to do just with just slap,
bump,
roll,
let's do it.
Kind of a thing,
you know?
But I mean you've got to do a crack.
You don't feel like you don't lose your temper are going,
I'm going to go in mad.
You just,
you can address the problem,
but the key isn't about like,
okay,
I'm good at,
you know,
bringing up in,
in going through barriers in regards to confrontation.
It's not that it's that barrier no longer produces that response so I can dance
up to the barrier.
If it gets cross,
it gets crossed,
you know,
and it's like whatever.
I'm not nervous about it.
More comfortable crossing the barrier if need be,
whatever.
Ideally,
yes,
ideally I'm not going to try to cross the barrier as far as being good terms,
bad terms.
I'm not going to try golden bed terms anytime,
you know,
or be impolite or something.
I don't think it's not,
I mean that's more depends on what kind of person you are I think.
I think,
um,
but like I said,
the key for me or the,
the,
the element,
the critical element,
there was that barrier.
How I felt about being near it or crossing it or not crossing or whatever.
Um,
it didn't cure it,
but it helps so much ultra.
Okay.
I won't make the story along,
but that we,
we are all hoping,
actually this was actually after I started.
You did too,
but just an example.
So I was doing video work for,
for this guy
and I to say who it doesn't matter.
Um,
and he had found out that I was doing other video work.
I Dunno,
maybe you had a sense of like owner,
I don't know.
He knew that or he found out or knew that I was doing video for it.
Not a competitive thing or nothing like that,
but just other video,
we're kind of like,
hey wait,
you're not spending all your time on my stuff kind of thing.
That's what I got the sense of.
But nonetheless,
and it had to do with travel,
you know,
so I was traveling here and I'm like,
Hey,
I gotta go cause I have to travel now to this other place.
And it's Kinda like,
that's where I felt it nonetheless.
So
the video wasn't due til like this certain date.
And then I was like,
yeah,
my prediction,
I should have it by this date,
which was way ahead of the date by the way.
And then that day I didn't have it and I was like,
Oh,
you know,
I didn't think it was going to be a big deal because it just didn't seem like a
big deal.
Your predicted date didn't get there.
It wasn't the due date.
Right,
right.
Not even.
Yeah.
And then,
um,
so I was like,
oh,
I don't have it,
you know,
if,
I've been working on it,
but you know,
I don't have it.
Maybe tomorrow,
like something like that and the kind of like,
maybe like one hour I'll have it for you.
It wasn't an hour,
but it was like all happy to you soon.
And,
and he was like,
I've thought,
given kind of our history of whatever,
I thought he would be like,
okay,
well,
cool.
Tomorrow we'll see it tomorrow.
I'm excited to see it kind of a thing.
That's what I was expecting.
Um,
but he was like,
he was like,
oh,
okay,
tomorrow.
Uh,
you know,
I'm really disappointed that you don't have it for me right now.
And I was really expecting to have to see something and I'm really disappointed
that you don't have anything for me right now.
And I was like,
boom,
heart beating.
This is on the phone too,
by the way.
There's not like,
oh,
I was,
you know,
confronted in anything is just that in pro to the point where I didn't even know
what to say.
I was like,
I don't even know what I said.
I think it was just the kind of like,
I didn't say anything and it was like,
so is that maybe one of the,
one of the things that's caused you to really hold back on making a bunch of
videos for Johnny
because there's a bunch of us that want to make that phone call to you.
Well,
if that was appointed,
just so you know,
we listened to this podcast,
we're disappointed.
If that were the case,
wouldn't it?
Wouldn't I be making videos every single day if that were the case?
Well,
I wish,
well,
what can we do differently over here on our end?
Anyway,
that was the,
that's an example
because really when I think about it back like that's not a big confrontation.
Probably had a lot to do with Xq team anyway,
but yeah,
for some reason though,
generally speaking,
the Jujitsu helped
as long as you have is you have genuine intentions.
I think,
hey,
that confrontation is going to come.
Cool.
Next question.
The serious question is about question,
indirect approach.
I have a history of starting things and then giving up on them when I get bored.
I'm the same way,
by the way,
or anyway.
A friend of mine is the same.
I'm working on it by sticking with one thing,
making a website,
which will be done in two weeks.
I called my friend once a month and he always tells me about some new
harebrained idea that he never acts on.
I've tried suggesting that he picked one thing and stick with it,
but he immediately shuts down.
How can I take the indirect approach and get him to actually follow through on
things?
Okay.
So you're trying to help your friend prioritize and execute,
which is
good to go.
Your friend sounds like he needs to prioritize and execute and get some follow
through going on with that as well.
I would say this,
you want to do a little indirect there.
What I might do with him is get involved in a project with them.
Mike,
pick one of those when he calls up with a zone,
these harebrained ideas and you think it's a decent one.
Say Okay Cool,
let's rock and roll with that.
I want to get in the game
and then
lay out some deadlines like,
Hey,
this is what we need to get done by here.
This is what we needed to be done by this point.
I'll do these four items.
You do these four items and that's what we'll get going.
Here's the due date.
That will get them done by so we can make this launch.
Boom.
Right?
And then you deliver your end,
you deliver your end and then when he doesn't,
now you can have a better discussion.
That's not so aggressive.
You have a reason for it,
you know?
And then,
you know,
maybe even subtly tell him that you're,
hey,
can I,
I'm going to go ahead and go proceed further with your idea.
Like I'm,
you're not going to do it.
It just became my idea.
Right?
Cause you're not going to execute because he needs to understand that idea.
People.
That's great.
I'm glad you have a lot of great ideas,
but it doesn't help.
Doesn't get anything done.
And ideas without executions,
ideas without execution,
the ideas themselves literally do not exist.
Your idea is worthless.
It's totally worthless if you don't execute on it.
So
you have to execute the execution of ideas into life.
Right?
That's what it is.
When you,
when you execute an idea,
it's creation.
It's not dreaming,
it's not thinking it's doing.
You are creating something and that's awesome.
Like just creation is,
is an awesome thing to be a part of and it's an awesome thing to lead and to
take an idea and turn it into something that's real and create and deliver it.
That's,
yeah,
that's just a hugely rewarding thing in life.
And he obviously probably hasn't experienced that many times.
And so how can you let him know that,
let them know that you know,
ideas mean nothing without execution.
And our goal is to create something.
And again,
I think the best way to do it is to join forces with them and drag them along so
he can get that feeling of the satisfaction of how good it feels to make
something happen.
Now the bad news is
if he doesn't look like if he doesn't do his things,
he doesn't do his part.
You can coach him,
you can prod them along,
you can do what you can to help him.
But
eventually you got to go out and make things happen on your own.
I mean that's just what you gotta do and you can't,
it's very hard.
I can some,
I can see you can't,
but it's very,
very difficult to help people that don't want to be helped that don't recognize
their errors that I've there.
Your Egos too.
Cause a lot of people that are idea people,
they'll,
they'll literally tell you that,
you know,
a global idea guy.
I'm an idea guy is what I do over here.
And,
and you know,
you say,
okay cool,
I'm gonna go over here and actually make things happen.
So by,
by your ideas.
So if it's someone that's arrogant like that,
because that's,
that's a level of arrogance,
right?
Hey,
look,
I don't do this little labor stuff.
I'm not a guy about execution.
What I do is I have ideas,
brilliance.
That's what I do over here.
That's those people aren't Auger help you.
Yeah.
So eventually you do what you can to help them out.
You try and get them involved in some of your projects.
Help.
Hopefully you can get him all the way through a project where he can see the,
and feel the gratification of success and execution and creation.
But if he never tastes that blood,
he's,
he's going to be a vegetarian.
That's the way it's going to go down.
He's going to be a salad eater.
And that's not good.
Nothing wrong with eating salads,
by the way.
No.
I eat salad with steak on them
brought,
that's so true.
So my brother,
we know him,
Jj,
he does apps like obviously you know his,
his company,
they do apps.
So apps,
uh,
let's say,
I'm just saying in general now,
apps,
websites,
video in my case.
So these are things,
there's other,
the other industries and skills,
whatever.
But these are the things that attract to the idea of people.
Hey,
I got an idea for the,
for the video,
I got an idea for an APP.
I get an idea for a website,
I've got to eat.
So we,
me and my brother were,
we attract these people,
right?
So it's like when you encounter that,
it's kind of like me saying,
I have an idea for the cure for cancer.
So what it does is it goes in and it targets just the cancer cells and it leaves
all the other sales alone.
All of them just leave them alone.
Just just kills the cancer cells.
So let's say in like,
I don't know,
a hundred years that happens,
right?
And I'm like,
no bro.
No it wasn't.
It wasn't here.
I did.
I use,
I mean,
not just like you said,
it's a,
it gets,
and to say it gets annoying.
I mean that's kind of maybe not the most accurate way,
for lack of a better term.
It's real interesting that it's not that clear to people.
You know when,
if you're,
because the execution is everything.
The idea that,
I think it might've been Tim Ferriss some,
so we were saying ideas worth like super,
like the super small amount all even go further and say it's literally worth
nothing just like you do.
He's like I said,
I guess there's some granularity of,
of you know what's weird?
It's,
it's a dichotomy because the idea is the worthless and at the same time it's the
most valuable thing but it only gets valued if it gets executed on.
Otherwise it has zero value.
Yeah.
And to the execution part execution because here's what you get to,
and I actually in a way was kind of one of these people where I'd be like why
have all these cool ideas?
So the first thing I'm going to do when I get this idea,
I'm going to go buy the domain name,
right?
I'm going to get,
you know,
sell this,
whatever and buy the domain name.
Cause I'm doing,
I'm executing.
Boom,
step one.
So that,
that's what this guy's doing.
The,
you know,
this guy who has these ideas and stuff,
this is ready or some form of the domain,
domain name,
the domain name.
Um,
he might,
you know,
you might see if the trademark or whatever is,
taken in all this stuff,
it would register and you know,
once the,
once the starts you'd be like,
ah,
well I'm kind of bored.
Right?
Yeah.
That was the think board of that.
And meanwhile,
like that's usually the fun part.
You know,
the excitement,
oh I see all the potential,
you know,
all this stuff.
But when the reality starts hitting and you know,
the hills get steeper and still the hard work that the actual part of any ideas
being materialized yet when that comes to view or comes into,
you know,
into play,
that's when they quote unquote get bored.
And when you take one,
maybe two steps back,
this,
it's really clear because
you,
you consider the percentage of people just in life who are successful in like
their dream thing.
I'm a computer programmer and now I own a computer programming business.
I don't know.
That's my example.
The amount of people who have that actually happening are really few and
furthermore you ask any one of those people.
It was never like I had the idea,
I bought the domain name.
Three weeks later we were moving.
It's never that.
It's like,
oh my gosh,
flop on my face.
Fail years.
Decades.
A lot of the time,
you know it's a grind.
Grind.
Yeah and that and that's all that execution,
right?
They're executing is hard.
One time I still contact lenses,
you know the colored contact lenses,
so it's totally illegal.
I shouldn't have done it.
I imported them from,
I dunno,
nine important,
but I bought them from a website where you going back to the values conversation
with kind of putting people's eyesight at risks and go make a dollar.
Well they weren't prescription.
They're all good.
You can buy them.
It was just like,
but nonetheless I bought them and they,
they'd only take like five days to get here.
So I knew how to make websites,
I knew how to do all that stuff.
So I just made a website,
colored contact lenses,
you know,
and I knew about SEL and stuff like that.
I just made the website,
you know,
eight bucks a month or something,
or a year.
For the domain website it was free because jade had the platform where you can
make websites.
So I sold a bunch of contexts.
Halloween time comes around,
perfect.
SCL,
call it contact San Diego by him from me.
People would buy them and be like,
well you buy one and everybody would just buy it from the website comes in and
just send them to that
execution.
Oh,
so you're,
you're proud of this?
I am not proud of selling contact.
I'm proud of the execution part.
Good job.
And then it's sort of got bored,
bored with it.
So.
All right,
next question.
Let's go to the next question.
Or this one time
Jocko.
I was wondering what your opinion was on when to start a child in Jujitsu.
My daughter was in the game at age seven and I'm on the mats as well.
My son is three and a half and it has expressed that he's very ready to start as
well.
My concern is starting him too young,
him getting crushed and falling out of love with Jujitsu before he has a chance
to fall in love with it.
This is the romance.
So,
uh,
okay.
So completely dependent on the maturity of the kid.
Yeah.
And um,
how old was your daughter when she started training to,
to I'll tell you about the circumstances.
No,
two to straight up too.
She,
she's really mature,
really smart and athletic and durable.
So that's,
that's like as young as you're going to get.
Yeah.
Um,
and,
and what,
what,
how many times a week would you go to and was there other small children in the
class?
Yes.
You had some kind of an ret,
you knew somebody that was all springing their kid or something like that.
They had a good playmate in there.
I need to make,
it's kind of a long all I'll tell you about it for sure.
Um,
basically it's,
uh,
you don't,
Matt Becker and them,
it's uh,
it's Gracie certified training center.
Yes.
It's a smaller gym,
but so you know,
they have programs for younger kids or whatever and it's essentially like you
modify the young kids wrote,
which is like for playing,
it's playing.
That's what it is.
But here's the thing you learned,
you did some moves for sure.
And in there you'll say you'll teach them that this is Jujitsu.
They don't know that you're there.
They're going to the person down.
They know that it's a mount in their thinking.
They're going trying to get out of the mountain.
They just think they're just trying to get off the bottom and they have games
where you balance on stuff and it works on their balance.
And you had these,
you know the myths that you hit point to him.
They line them up and you get to for sure walking on the boat.
So they play all these games.
But it's crazy how like,
it's like karate kid man,
you don't want to cry again when it's like sand the wax on wax off in there and
they get good at the wax on,
wax off cause it's kind of fun.
Well wax on,
wax off from that fun.
But the stuff you do in there is fun.
And then when they're like,
okay,
who?
And it's really you,
you got to find the right person.
The right teacher has been mad,
but he was like,
he's so gentle kids because there's other young kids running around,
you know,
they're not,
he knows.
He knows not everyone's going to be paying attention.
And so they got to know how to deal with kids.
But yeah,
man,
she,
she took it and who was it was good.
Yeah.
And,
and there's some kids that are 11 and 12 years old that aren't ready for
Jujitsu.
Yeah.
They're just not there yet.
And I would also say less is more for a young kid.
You know,
you don't want to just burn them out.
Don't smoke them on that everyday.
Make 'em look forward,
pull them off the mat.
They want to stay a little longer.
Hey,
we got to go.
I mean,
you won't let them have some fun,
but,
um,
I burned my kids out.
Yeah,
man.
Um,
and I backed off in time for my son because he was younger and it didn't cause
my,
my daughters,
I was like,
compete,
train,
compete.
Oh,
I'm going to put you in the heavier weight class.
The older kids bracket.
I mean I just did it wrong,
right?
Just did it wrong and,
and I didn't
back off in time.
And so now they train,
you know,
I mean not as much as they should.
Right.
My son turns all the time.
Um,
but I did a bad job of making Jujitsu fun.
Right.
Cause that's,
and that's what,
you know,
that's why I like you.
The fact that this question,
he said,
am I starting with two younger?
He's going to get crushed.
Hey,
you shouldn't,
you know,
Jim,
that you take your three and a half year old child to,
should be allowing him to get crushed.
That shouldn't be happening.
So if you have a good gym where you've got the right instructor,
um,
that then go and let them have fun and make sure it just stays fun in any,
if they don't love it,
you,
you can't make them love it.
It's not going to happen.
Now this is a good story.
One of my son's friends who I always want all everyone to turn to do it through
obviously what this guy is,
a friend of mine I've known for a long time and his has a son that's my son's
age.
And so they kind of grown up together and you know,
my son's always train in Jujitsu and I would say,
hey,
you know,
when they were six years old,
hey,
have your son come in and try it.
Came in and tried it.
One to hate it.
Hm.
Year later now,
you know,
a year and I don't know,
something like that.
13 months,
18 months or something.
It comes in a year later,
tries it again.
He's like now seven years old.
Hates it.
Just doesn't like it.
Can't stand it.
Then comes in at,
you know,
nine years old,
comes in,
loves it.
I'm turning to everyday now.
Do you know what mean?
Trans all the time and,
and you know,
now he's my,
and,
and they'll tell you what this is,
what's cool is that he's,
it's not like he's a million years.
It's not so,
so my son trained three years more or maybe even four years more than,
than this other kid.
My son is that kid caught up.
Right?
I mean,
my son is still a little bit bit,
but a little bit better,
but they're in the same game right there.
It's not like,
it's not like that.
My son has this massive lead.
No,
the kid loves it and you can learn,
you can learn and get better,
you know,
at any age.
But my point in saying that is forcing him to be in it for those three years
would not have helped.
He would've,
he would've quit Jujitsu completely,
but just haven't shown it to them and saying,
Hey,
this is what you do.
And you know,
he didn't like getting choked.
Right.
And,
and maybe that's me.
It was my buddy's son.
So,
hey,
let's,
let's get after it a little bit.
And then we weren't letting them get chokes,
but he just didn't like the Claustrophobia of it.
Right in there is claustrophobia.
You're gonna feel that even in,
even in a gentle situation with a six year old,
if you get held down,
you don't like it.
You know,
he didn't like it.
Yeah.
Now he's holding people down himself.
So you,
you,
you basically what I'm saying is forcing someone to a kid to do something for
two years.
You think you're getting this value,
two years worth of value.
You're not getting two years worth of value.
You're actually going though direction.
So you might as well just let them try it occasionally.
And I say that sometimes will
at my gym,
they'll,
hey,
you know,
my son just doesn't want to do it right now.
And I go,
no problem.
Hey,
you know what I say?
They say,
I just want to make them call and go,
don't make him come.
I go,
Let him come.
When he wants to you,
you'd,
you're gonna stop your membership.
That's cool.
If he wants to come in on Saturdays and bring him in,
you know,
he wants to come in once,
once a month to just do,
keep him familiar.
Do that.
Just do that.
You don't grind their brains out when they're whatever little kids,
big kids.
I think
you know how
you say like did you two should be fun.
So the
if,
okay,
so,
you're watching a Bronx tale,
your bullets that,
okay.
There's a part on that where we're a,
you know these biker guys,
they're in the bar,
you know,
causing trouble.
Exactly right.
So that's what it is.
And this is what,
this is what this guy got to be here.
Okay.
So for those who've never seen Bronxdale,
these biker guys are in the bar and they're like causing trouble and all this
stuff.
And,
and then the people that,
hey,
you guys please a mobsters now mobsters say,
hey guys,
please leave.
You need to get out of here.
And they're like,
hey,
we'll do whatever we want.
And he's like,
no,
no.
They're like,
okay,
we'll leave.
Let me get one beer in.
The Guy said,
all right,
one more beer.
And they grabbed the beer in these,
shake the beer all over it.
And then now this stuff.
So anyway,
they locked the doors and say,
hey,
we asked you to leave.
Now you can't leave bad situation for the biker.
So this is what,
in my opinion,
and this guy has to avoid.
Like if his son three and a half,
it's like Dang,
I'm showing interest.
I want to get kind of get on the mats on a jump in here,
I see what's going on.
It looks like fun.
I'm gonna jump in,
don't be like,
Hey,
you want to get in now you can't leave.
Don't do that kind of stuff.
Do I leave the door open right to yes,
exactly.
So as you know,
press three and a half now where she went to Matt Becker's for awhile and
learned it and it was cool.
And now I just bring her with me just once a week.
When I go on Fridays or whatever.
Um,
he,
I'd bring her with me.
I don't tell her jumping in the class and just come be familiar with the mat to
sit dead ruling.
You see Jocko rural and you see Andy,
you know,
and she has fun.
They want to talk to you and she's pretty outgoing.
She has flattened out now.
She just likes that the message is fun.
You don't have to worry.
She,
he,
she hangs with them.
She coaches you.
Crystal son is there.
Yeah.
She,
she cheers for me.
Yeah.
But you know,
crystal son is their favorite Jujitsu guy though.
I know.
I think it was Andy.
Yeah,
sorry.
Oh,
so you know,
so she likes it.
She's familiar.
Familiar.
I'm not going to say,
hey,
we're here,
so we got to get our reps today.
No,
it's not that when she wants to come like Molly and she will,
she'll be like,
Hey,
I'll let me show this guy.
There was,
um,
I forget his name,
but he's like,
Hey,
let me show him out.
And there's this whole series that she learned from my,
you know,
like finding the arms and keeping the balance,
all this stuff.
And she likes to do it,
you know,
so now she always wants to go.
There you go.
And when and at,
at home or whatever,
one,
you know,
my mom comes and visits,
she's like,
Hey,
let me show grandma came out and she wants to do it,
you know?
Beautiful.
And yeah,
so that'll keep her in the game.
And when she starts getting a lot more ability,
you know,
age like three and a half,
Nelson like let's take four or five,
six,
seven,
yeah,
she's going to start to realize,
oh shoot,
I can do this stuff now.
You know,
because all these little things that I learned just by playing around really.
And that's kind of what you want with that.
But if it's,
if they look at it,
this thing that my dad forced me to do it so hard and claustrophobic,
Yep.
Guys sweating on me and I'm losing the whole time cause they just started and
I'm rolling with Thor the whole time and he's,
you know,
killing me or whatever.
And that's my experience.
My whole regard for the Jujitsu is going to be like,
yeah,
this isn't fun.
There's also a little bit of rebellion in all,
in most children in like my,
one of my daughters,
she doesn't want to train Jujitsu,
but she wrestles in high school,
so that's awesome.
I think that's an exam,
but she almost does that just to be,
you know.
No,
I wrestle a little.
Does she know she got flagged?
She got flanked,
but yeah,
man,
I think so.
I mean,
back to the question,
I think that um,
they're given a certain type of teacher,
which I mean the demands on the teacher for,
you know,
a young Ian's courier.
Yeah.
It's so hard.
So you gotta it's rare to find a teacher,
especially if you have a teacher who doesn't like do that,
you know,
if it's like,
okay,
I'm going to make an exception for this.
Cause I seen guys,
they're comfortable,
their friends in the gym kind of thing and they're like,
yeah,
my kids do,
but we all like each other.
Right?
Then,
hey,
jump in the kids class,
he's two,
he's running around and he's interrupting the class.
Like,
yeah,
it's not,
it's not good if the kid's not ready.
And the teacher,
that's not a compatible situation up.
This kid's not ready.
We'll say,
hey,
your kid's not ready.
Yeah,
you can't.
You can't be in here.
Yeah,
come back in six months.
You want to bring them in and we'll watch on Saturdays.
Cool.
Good.
How familiar you do you bring them in to watch?
It's the time we're going,
you know?
Hopefully he's not disruptive.
Hopefully.
Well,
they can't be disruptive or they can't stay.
Right,
right,
right.
You can't do that.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
yeah,
so in that case,
you know,
it's not going to work,
but uh,
yeah.
That's it.
Just like how you said,
just open the door.
I'm cruising in here.
It'll look to see if the door's open.
I'm cruising here.
I'm doing fun stuff.
Come on in.
I'm not going to close the door.
I'm not going to go a Bronx tale on you.
You know?
That's how you do it.
My opinion
check.
All right.
When we got time for one more.
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
Have you most,
okay,
Jocko.
I have mostly lived a life dominated by doubt and fear.
What are your thoughts on how I can step into bravery?
You know what?
I actually took this question from Twitter and I answered the question in one
word.
You've lived a life dominated by doubt and fear.
How do you step into bravery?
Yep.
That that's how you step into bravery step.
Take the step
step aggressively towards your fear and that that step towards your fear is the
step into bravery
because we're scared of what we don't know.
And
there is only one way to learn and to know and that is to confront that fear.
You have to step,
you have to go.
And this simple action,
simple attitude.
It answers so many questions.
So many questions.
How do you get to the gym every day
you step,
you go,
how do you,
how do you change your diet?
Do step
you go,
how do you overcome fear of failure?
Fear of success or,
or fear of fear itself.
You step
and how do you face the fear of the unknown?
You step.
Don't wait anymore.
Don't think anymore.
Don't plan anymore.
Don't contemplate anymore.
Don't make any more excuses or justifications.
Don't rationalize anything else.
No,
no and no.
Instead be aggressive.
Take Action now.
And what is the first action that you need to take?
What's the first step you need to take?
The first step you need to take is just that
step.
And I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
So
speaking of stepping
echo,
Charles,
if somebody wanted to step up and support this podcast,
what would be a good step in making that happen?
Okay,
before we go into that,
good day today
where your bars came in.
I mentioned,
I tried the Jalapeno one anyway,
came in today.
Outstanding.
Um,
I've been,
you know,
this,
I've been Kinda Kinda off had the stomach flu,
two Mris on my knee to see what up to knees,
you know,
so I kind of been out of the game two weeks out of the game.
Today was my first day back in the game.
First Day back in the game,
did a metcon,
lifted some weights,
didn't do these huge budgets yet,
but um,
yeah,
fully functional.
All good life.
That's meaning again.
Then the warrior bars coming.
Good day for Echo Charles.
Great Day.
Um,
where are your bars on it or your births when we talk about this before.
So right back to the supporting of the podcasting.
I know you're like,
what does that have to do with support in the podcast?
So on it worry is on,
it is supplements.
I remember back in the day
when I first,
not first but me a few years into lifting,
you know,
people,
they'll just get supplements,
right?
Joe Wieder super weight gain.
2000.
Exactly.
Waking 2000,
you know,
all the Beta Gin,
fossil,
the gin,
creatine,
you know,
even though apparently creatine is good thing.
Anyway,
I,
for Real,
I found that supplements,
no supplements,
no factor.
It doesn't even make a difference.
Like when I was on supplements like Weight Gainer,
I didn't gain a bunch of weight no more than it would without the supplements.
Anyway,
the point there is supplements are whack in my opinion.
And what I found out that you focus on the wrong thing on as far as
supplementation goes,
it's going to be whacked.
So on it.com/jocko/jacket because that's where the 10% off.
But I'm going to get to that.
Don't worry.
This has to do with supporting the podcast.
So,
so on it they have the correct supplements and not only the correct supplements,
the good co,
because supplements don't have to be anything.
They don't have to be,
you have chopped pills.
I mean we really increase your mood and I dunno whenever increasing your weight
gain,
whatever.
But these are like legit and one of the few anyway.
And okay,
so if you want to supplement something,
don't get like weight gainers.
You know,
if you want to gain weight,
you can do that in the correct way without supplements.
This is what you supplement,
what you know,
as you wear and tear your joints,
your joints don't get much blood flow like compared to muscles.
So they tend to get more wear and tear with less.
Like as far as speedy recovery goes,
your muscle recover quicker than your joints.
That's what I'm saying.
You know,
supplement something.
It's a little bit that,
that needs supplementation.
If you're getting after it.
Krill oil,
that was a big lead in,
um,
look,
I could say take Krill oil.
It'll help your joints.
You're like,
okay,
you know,
because every commercial or every word,
there'll be ready to take this little help this you need like some contact
context and like the information that kind of backs it up,
you know,
it got to be real and this is real.
Nonetheless.
Krill oil is one of the supplements that I recommend for your joints.
I told the story about how when I get out of bed and I'd be like all jacked up
because my daughter wouldn't jump on my back right out of bed.
You're like,
you got a warm up for that kind of stuff.
Typically,
but not,
not anymore.
Cause I had been on the Krill oil strong bone by the way,
for your joints as well.
It's not strong bones strong.
Strawn boom.
Yeah.
I don't know the uh,
I don't know the reason for that.
It's just dope like that if you're looking for it.
No.
Gee,
that's John.
That's for joints and stuff.
Uh,
what else did you say?
Oh,
Alpha brain of course.
So the point behind all this deck,
shroom tech,
here's what shroom tech does.
I think everybody knows what it does.
Here's the thing.
I don't think so.
I be like,
Hey,
it makes you get after it for longer or whatever.
Listen to podcasts.
Every time we say what is from tech knows,
I'm going to clarify.
Okay.
You know what?
Go for it.
Unless it back.
Okay.
Clarify to clarify it to you and just agree or disagree if this is correct.
Okay,
so I don't even have to use scientific terms.
I'm just put into perspective.
So if I'm gonna own it,
it's not,
I'm not an none of that.
You haven't had enough alpha brain do scientific terms right now.
So just use whatever terms.
Okay,
I'm going to do a metcon.
They'd use them quickly.
They do in that car,
I'm going to do like 10 rounds did you did to five rounds and used to whatever.
If I'm not on shroom tech sport,
by the way,
this tomb tech immune as well,
but she takes words so it helps you like utilize oxygen.
So what that means is when you hit the,
you know when you,
when you're like in a car where it goes to the,
when you're red lining,
that needle's hitting the red Bro.
You can't,
you can't pull ahead when you're in the red,
can't pull ahead when you're in the red.
No that,
so if you're not in the shroom tech and you hit the red and don't be halfway
through your workout when you're,
the needle was hitting their ed,
your red line and already you can't go past,
you can't push through what the shroom tech does.
If you have that in you,
that needle won't go towards the right.
It'll go up there,
it'll go the green,
maybe even in the yellow,
and it'll hang in the yellow and you're pushing hard halfway,
three quarters,
last minute,
two minutes of the round.
You won't even be by the red.
You'll still be in the yellow.
That's what the shroom tech does.
Agree.
Boom.
There you go.
We'll pick the shroom tech.
Shroom tech sport,
by the way.
Okay,
so now the slash.
Ajiaco what that signifies is you get 10% off.
Good deal.
I would say retail price is for suckers.
I would say that,
but it's not true.
I'm pretty real.
Retail if you want or just go to [inaudible] dot com and just get it,
don't get the 10% off 100% up to you.
Nonetheless,
you've got the shroom tech,
you've got the warrior bars.
It's like this dope thing as well.
Look into that.
Krill oil for your joints.
Get all that stuff.
In my opinion,
it helps.
That's why it's not like the Beta Gin power game 5,000 where it doesn't help.
This is the frill kind.
That helps.
I understood.
There you go.
We're good.
I'm telling him to leave y'all.
I'm telling everybody else.
You're over here like already know this.
I know you already no this but you know you got to put into perspective
sometimes you just certainly did on it.com/jocko this other things on there and
you can just kind of know.
You know when you,
when you,
when you get there,
you're going crazy for honor right now.
Here's the thing I like on it.
I'm going crazy.
You like it a lot more apparently tonight.
Yeah,
because I do feel like if I would've known this like what I'm saying now,
oh,
like before because I'm slowly getting new stuff.
Of course I got the word bar and I took Shreem tech before.
I know that,
but I'm like looking,
they got a new like recovery,
a pre workout and recovery drink.
It's all in one.
And I'm like,
Bro,
if I would've known all this,
I would've gotten him being in the game with this stuff a long time ago.
So you're,
you're providing a public,
so I'm sure you going to stand right now.
I'm letting it be known.
Right?
We're good.
Anyway,
I'm just going to sit over here.
I'll tell you another one that it got off the written law.
How,
I guess it's on the record,
but it's like a,
it's not peanut butter.
You know how they have almond butter,
but it's like an almond cashew.
It's like a mixed nut butter.
It's pretty dope from on it on it.
I might have to try that.
Yeah.
Um,
one of the major keys is that it's like legit quality.
Get 10% off.
If you go to [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko or just go to [inaudible] dot com
and get 0% off whatever you like.
You know another way to support
is the Amazon click through.
That's like what is,
if you don't know you go to or websites Jocko,
podcast.com over on the side to the right you'll see just some basic Amazon
banner.
You Click through there before you do shopping.
You're Christmas shopping or your everyday shopping and I'm,
that kind of supports the podcast.
It makes Amazon or Amazon gives us like a little kickback.
That's a good way to support.
I made the comparison to little piece of sodium.
It's like seems like this teeny tiny thing cause just clicking through Amazon
and shopping,
whether that's a teeny tiny three second effort,
but it does a big deal,
you know,
as far as supporting.
So it means we don't have to run advertisements on the podcasts.
Yeah,
which I hate,
which I don't believe I'm going to do it.
Not going to do aside from Onnit would technically that's,
well,
you know,
but I was taking on it before this.
I'm telling you anyway,
but you know what?
Hold on a second while we go to a commercial break.
Yeah,
no,
don't want to do that.
Yeah.
This isn't even a commercial break.
This is the
part of,
this is the deal.
We're doing it together.
I'm going to remember to do this.
I'm going to do like fake commercials during the next podcast or like in a
podcast.
In the future I'm gonna do fake commercials and make everyone just suffer
through fake commercials just to see how much it,
it's horrible.
And then say if you never want to hear that again,
click through Amazon.
Amazon.
Yeah.
That's a,
that's a good way though.
Speaking of fake commercials.
So I did these two fake commercials,
made them videos.
I've seen him Bardis beer and then there's part is prime,
which is like 40 ounce.
It's a lot of racial stereotypes.
No,
but nonetheless.
Oh,
back to the Amazon.
Click through thing.
That's a good way to support.
So be the,
be the sodium.
If you,
if you understand,
um,
and of course subscribe to the podcast on iTunes.
That's a,
that's a big deal.
Um,
and leave a review man.
If you're in the mood,
do you read the reviews?
I do read the reviews and what I noticed was I was looking at some other reviews
today cause I was reading,
I read our reviews today to see if there's any good input.
There was good stuff.
I looked at other what,
what this kind of got me motivated to see is that the people that write our
reviews,
they're getting in the game.
They're writing full paragraphs with detailed likes and pros and cons and all
that.
You go to some other peoples that have feedback on nurse that has just two
words,
good podcasts or I love it.
I love it.
Five stars that's I love at FiveStars is a lot different than someone saying.
What I really like about the Jocko podcast is that they go into detail on these
leadership elements that have helped me in the following ways,
but,
and you go through the whole thing.
Yeah.
That's really good.
Support.
The podcast.
I'll tell you this about that because really when you think about it,
if you're just like,
and some of them were funny by the way,
and the ones for,
for Jocko t that aren't Amazon,
I'm going to have to figure out a way to publish those or do something with
them.
Cause some of them are are awesome.
Eric's,
Eric's was insane,
but there's been a few of them.
Yeah,
those are good.
I retweeted a bunch of them.
Yeah.
So everybody thinks it's a little hard to retweet them.
So I had to,
I have to figure out a way to retweet them better,
the capture screenshot or something.
But they're so good.
They're so funny.
Some of them are pretty wordsmith s oh,
some of them are long.
Some of them,
it takes me six minutes to read it and I want to actually highlight stuff and
take notes and do the deal.
But yeah,
that's it.
That's a good in there.
Well,
when you think about it,
even if the,
if someone's in the mood to write a review and they're just like deck gift,
great podcast,
five stars.
I see.
Do that.
That's true too.
It doesn't have to be long.
You what that is when people are like,
this is what I like about it or whatever.
That's just all it is.
Is the result of someone being
in the mood to write a review in genuinely writing it
fricking awesome.
Beyond writing it.
I'd say that qualifies is getting after getting after it.
Yeah.
So you know,
you see unmitigated discipline and all things or is it getting after it in all
the big day daily.
You're missing the word daily.
Daily,
Yeah.
Anyway,
yeah.
Just medicating daily discipline and all things.
Yup.
And getting after it and I'll think,
I know that's new,
but still we're going with it.
So please write a review.
Subscribe to Youtube.
We're doing some more videos on top of the podcast videos,
excerpts,
some excerpt.
Tell Echo on Twitter what excerpts you want so he doesn't have to figure out
what you want.
Just tell him what you want.
Give them the the podcast and the times time hack.
He'll pull it out.
I'll put it on there.
Yeah,
I will.
that's,
I think that the challenge I think is going back and finding them,
but that,
you know what,
that's not a challenge is not shot.
Well it is,
but it is a little bit,
cause you might not,
if something might not have struck you the way it struck someone else.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
And so if it's striking one person out there,
it's probably striking at least four or five more people that want to hear that
excerpt.
So let's give it to them.
So tell echo podcast number,
timestamp.
That would be easy for you,
right?
Yes.
Cause we don't want to stress you out.
Don't stress delicate.
We know that we're were sensitive to that.
We don't want to be disappointed in you except if you're Brady,
Lisa,
Debby,
Andy,
anyone that we don't be like,
hey I liked this timestamp because like we said your name on the podcast make x
or don't say that.
So those people kind of can't do that.
Why not?
All right.
Well I guess we're saying they shouldn't be there listening.
They probably have good input and he's on,
it's going to be like 20 seconds song.
Hey,
that part where you meant good and 20 seconds is fine.
It's what you need to understand that though.
People want to watch stuff that's 20 seconds long.
They don't want to watch 29 minutes.
That's why it's called an excerpt.
Jukka we got a store.
We do have a store.
It's called chocolate store.
Well yeah,
I know we already knew this,
but no real new developments there really.
But if you didn't know that is a good way to support and you get some stuff in
return.
It's a bone by shirt.
If you're down,
if you like them is wanting to Jacola's face on.
It says good backwards,
backwards.
So if you look in the mirror it's,
it's for you.
That message is for you
layers anyway.
Yeah,
it could look at,
there's rash guards,
their rash guards are good for,
you know,
the Jujitsu for any physical activity where you need range of motion.
Retrigger it's good.
They look good too according to people.
Here's a tip for the rash guards and I think for the shirts as well,
if you're one of those inbetweeners like that means your site like,
Hey,
I you were a large,
but if it fits slim,
I need an extra large like that kind of people.
It fits like this much slimmer.
Know that swift,
the rash guard betweener everything.
Rash guard and the shirts go big goal to the bigger size if you're an in between
or God.
Yeah,
for sure.
That's just the tip.
Good advice because the,
and that's good news for you though.
You know what,
out of the past 39 minutes you've been talking about this,
the way to support the podcast,
that was the most important thing that you've said.
That was the valuable piece of information.
Arguably.
Yeah.
I respect your opinion on the matter.
This is the women's stuff too.
Don't neglect the leaves.
This is in my opinion,
something that I overlooked.
If you want to support the Bobcat,
you know,
you know how it's like,
oh well my girl's birthday is coming up.
In this case,
Christmas coming up.
I only bought my wife one thing and it was,
it wasn't directed cause they don't have that creative thing.
If you're thinking that get them a discipline equals freedom,
women's tee shirt,
v-neck pink or black or whatever the color you like.
But there is pink.
If you won't be getting one of that against my,
that's it.
That'll have a two pronged effect.
Boom.
You get her a solid shirt that you didn't get at the swap meet their quality
stuff there.
They're good shirts.
You know,
we made it a point to get the good ones.
You've got a good quality shirt and she became instantly in the game.
Two pronged effect.
We'll get that for your wife if you want.
That's a suggestion and three pronged effects.
The part,
the podcast boom there it is.
Some hoodies in there as well for the cold weather and uh,
yeah,
some patches.
The official like two by three,
10 f d flat,
dark earth color official where with your uniform boom.
Available now as they say
Jacqueline,
startup.com.
Um,
also we've got Jocko white tea.
Now Jocko white tea is in apparently extremely high demand.
Why?
Because it tastes awesome and it also makes you feel good and it's got
antioxidants,
it which makes you healthier.
Yes.
And I'm not going to use any scientific terms,
I'm just going to tell you it's doing.
So it's been,
it's been in high demand.
We have logistical issues right straight up.
So it's showing up at Amazon.
It's getting going through their system,
just keep checking.
And we've got,
I told,
I told everyone that we would never run out of white.
You again.
This was a mistake promptly.
I did not understand the logistic challenges that we would be facing now.
I have not even doubled down,
not even tripled down.
I have quadrupled down to make the future bright.
We will get to a point in the future where we will literally never run out of
Jocko white tea.
But for now we,
but for now,
um,
keep checking back on Amazon.
Sign up for the little notification thing.
Cause when we,
when they clear it through their little system,
it shows up and everyone that has the notification is buying it immediately.
So it's running out.
The other day it was up for 18 minutes or something.
It was gone.
Wait,
what notification?
The Amazon,
the Amazon you can sign up for,
notify me when this is back in stock.
So when that happens,
boom,
you can order it immediately.
The mugs,
the mugs that say get after it on them and that have a little uh,
approved symbol with someone's head that looks a lot like me on it.
You can get those on Amazon as well and they're big.
They're bigger than normal because you figure that way you can fit more white
tea in it and be more better and you can get those.
Those are also same thing on Amazon.
Again,
I apologize,
but the way the system works,
they're coming in,
they show up and then they,
and then they take a certain amount of input them into the system,
but then they don't realize yet at Amazon,
Amazon doesn't,
they're not in the game yet to be quite honest with you.
They're not in the game.
They don't understand what's happening.
We're trying to explain it to them,
that people want mugs.
They want,
when they want mugs,
they also want ti to put into the monks were getting there.
Same thing.
Logistically,
we'll get to a point where we were,
where we will not run out amongst.
Now I don't know what the mugs will keep making forever.
I don't know.
Because once everyone has one,
then they'll say,
okay,
I got mine.
So then we'll stop making them.
But you can get them on Amazon.
You can get the t on Amazon,
you can get the reload,
which is a hundred bags.
You can get the 10,
which is quality container that you can then reload with the reload.
So do that.
That's on amazon.com.
Uh,
also extreme ownership muster number two in where?
New York City,
it's going to be May 4th and May 5th,
www.extremeownership.com go get registered,
do it fast.
The price does go up.
The closer we get to the date.
So a,
I don't want you to pay more.
B,
it's going to sell out.
So the faster you do it,
the better chance you have of going and of paying a lower price.
When we get there,
if you're thinking that I'm not going to sit there and talk to you and I'm not
going to sign your book and lace not going to sit there and talk to you and
life's not going to sign your book,
you're wrong.
We're going to sit there.
We're going to sign your book,
we're going to talk to you,
we're going to address your problems.
We're going to hang out.
We didn't go behind the curtain at all.
Zero Times.
Actually we did one when the thing was over,
we walked back off stage off off the,
off the stage and behind the curtain for about three minutes cause we were a
little bit fired up at that point and we just walked back there and
decompressed.
They came out and started signing books.
That was one time,
but the rest of the time,
oh,
we'd say,
okay everyone take a 10 minute break.
We'd go to the front and sign books,
right.
Boom.
Or talk to people or addressed something or whatever.
So this isn't a thing where you go and we're going to be,
uh,
you know,
behind the curtain and come out.
Like I'm a Rockstar and I'm not a rock star.
I'm not,
I'm not nothing.
And the,
my purpose of being here is to hang out.
So that's why we're going to the monster.
That's where we're having the muster.
So come to the muster New York City,
come and hang out.
You're going to learn something.
I'm going to learn something.
Oh yeah,
we're all gonna learn something and you're going to meet a bunch of people that
are,
I hate using this term.
Bunch of people that are likeminded,
right?
Cause really can do minds be like,
no,
they can't be.
But can two people,
three people,
300,
450 people,
they're going to be New York City that I want to get after it.
Can they be there?
Yes they can.
And they will be in force
until we get to the monster.
In the meantime,
if you want to talk to us,
it just so happens that we're all up in the Inter webs on Twitter,
on Instagram.
And as you might've seen.
So we also on that phase,
bookie,
Baja Echo,
echo is at Echo Charles and I am at Jocko Willink.
And to wrap this up,
thank you for listening.
Thank you for listening for the past year,
52 straight weeks,
no breaks.
But I want to say this,
I want to tell you something else and I want to make this clear.
Don't just listen.
Do,
um,
I'm not just talking so you know,
I'm not just talking,
I'm doing,
and I don't want you to just listen to put this information to work.
Make today count every day.
Yeah,
go forward.
Get aggressive and attack.
Whether it's on the battlefield or on the beat,
or in the factory Taree or on the farm,
or on the construction site,
or on the website,
in the garage or in the firehouse.
Don't hesitate,
step,
step forward.
Get after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko out.